Our first selection is the perennial favorite when Twilight falls on NGC 891.
Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 87. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße euch am 14. Mai 2008, die Sonne scheint bzw. schien. Der Abend bricht langsam über uns herein und wir nähern uns dieser heimliegen Atmosphäre, die so wunderbar geeignet ist, für wirklich aufschlussreiche Podcasts. Und ein solcher soll auch heute folgen. Thematisch geht es in die Welt der Radiowellen und wir wollen sprechen über softwarebasiertes Radio oder sagen wir einmal, wie man überhaupt den Frequenzen ein bisschen mit Software zu Leibe rücken kann. Und dazu frisch eingeflogen aus fernen Ländern, endlich mal wieder selten genug in der Heimatstadt eingekehrt, ist Harald Welte. Hallo. Sag mal hallo Harald.
Ja, ich sag hallo, ohne dass ich Harald hinterher sage, wie du gesagt hast, dass ich das sagen soll. Ja, ich nehme das mal als Kompliment.
Ja, du warst viel auf Reisen und hast unter anderem deine eigene Verleihungszeremonie verurlaubt, weil ich das richtig mitbekommen habe. Du bist ja Empfänger eines tollen Awards. Ich glaube, jeder muss mal in seinem Leben einen Award einheimsen. Bei dir ist es jetzt soweit und du hast nichts weniger eingesagt als den Free Software Foundation Award von Blood for the Advancement of Free Software.
Ja, das ist in der Tat eine Ehre, die mir zuteil geworden ist. Das hat mich sehr überrascht und gleichzeitig auch gefreut. Ich war ausnahmsweise mal im Urlaub. Das erlaube ich mir auch mal alle paar Jahre. Dann kam diese Verleihungszeremonie.
Wusstest du das schon vorher und bist deswegen in den Urlaub geflüchtet?
Nein, ich hatte erst den Urlaub gebucht, dann wurde ich informiert und ich sah mich nicht willens und oder in der Lage.
Den Wanteppich, den schicken, selber in Empfang zu nehmen. Hast du ihn jetzt mittlerweile?
Den habe ich mittlerweile.
Ist er so hübsch, wie immer gesagt wird?
Es gibt Fotos online.
Ja, mit GNU drauf und so.
Ja, es ist halt die Farbkombination, jetzt nicht ganz mein persönlicher Geschmack, aber ich glaube, das wäre...
Was tut man nicht alles um die freie Software?
Mit Ocker, leuchtend orange und braun, so in Ton.
Klingt so, als hätte Richard Stollman das selber ausgewählt und selber designt. Ist es so?
Das weiß ich nicht, also ich weiß quasi, dass es ge-outsourced ist, die Produktion, aber ob es das Design-Originär von Hans Stollman himself ist, das weiß ich nicht.
Aber es ist sicherlich approved, das ist ja stressig.
Stollman ist übrigens gerade eben in Taiwan und hat die letzten zwei Tage irgendwie Vorträge gehalten. Da fällt mir da noch ein, weil von wegen Fernost und so.
Wieso erwähnst du jetzt gerade Taiwan?
Na, weil du sagtest, ich komme aus fernen Ländern.
Das stimmt, ja, du bist ja sowieso eigentlich die ganze Zeit in fernen Ländern unterwegs. Es ist ja sehr schwierig, dich mal in Berlin anzutreffen. Aber im Urlaub warst du ja, also während der Zeremonie, wartest du glaube ich in Brasilien, wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe. Wo du ja auch schon mal viel Zeit verbracht hast, aber ich will das nicht so sehr in deine ganze persönliche Lebensgeschichte und Urlaubsplanung einsteigen. Aber ich wollte das nochmal erwähnt haben, weil es ja auch Dinge tangiert, die wir über Chaosradio Express schon besprochen haben. Vor allem wahrscheinlich, denke ich mal, war die Motivation, dein Engagement für das GPL-Violations-Projekt. Richtig, du bist ja auch ein Kontributor zum Linus-Code und so weiter. Aber das war natürlich jetzt, denke ich mal, die ausschlaggebende Geschichte. Da gab es gerade wieder News mit Skype. Was ist da passiert?
Ach, naja, es gibt da ja so nette Geräte, in denen unter anderem vielleicht auch ein Software-Defined Radio verbaut ist, fällt mir da gerade ein, sogenannte Voice-Over-IP-Telefone mit Wi-Fi-Fähigkeit. Und wie das so ist bei, ich würde sagen, wahrscheinlich inzwischen 60 bis 80% der embedded-Geräte, die man irgendwie bekommt, ist da Linux drauf. Und ja, die hat eben Skype vertrieben, hergestellt worden, die von SMC, und Skype hat seinerzeit den Vertrieb nicht um- beziehungsweise eingestellt auf ein GPL-kompatibles Verfahren. Und hat deswegen eine einstweilige Verfügung kassiert im vergangenen Jahr, im Juli. Angefangen hat das Ganze im Februar schon. Ist alles ein bisschen kompliziert, weil das Skype das alles schon juristisch so aufdröselt, dass man sie sehr schwer irgendwie erreichen kann. Also die Firma sitzt in Luxemburg, der Vertrieb kommt aus Spanien und verkauft, wenn die Dinger dann nach Deutschland. Und das war also von daher auch ein bisschen eine härtere Nuss, die wir üblicherweise knacken.
Das heißt auch ihre Business-Struktur ist so ähnlich wie ihr Protokoll irgendwie.
Obfuscated, ja, das könnte gleich auch sein.
Peer to peer. Na ja, auch da hat man ja schon ein bisschen reingeschaut. Mit anderen Worten, auch Skype hat sich beugen müssen, wie, ja, nicht die meisten, sondern eigentlich alle von den Unternehmen, die du bisher so angegangen hast. Das ist ja auch gut so, das bringt die Sache voran. Aber darüber wollten wir nicht reden. Das wollte ich nur noch mal nebenbei erwähnen. Aber jetzt haben wir es schon angesprochen. Der Fachbegriff ist Software Defined Radio. Was ist das?
Ja, generell ist es sozusagen das Radio des 21. Jahrhunderts, könnte man fast sagen. Man macht ja Radio- oder eben Funkkommunikation doch durchaus schon weit über 100 Jahre. Und man muss sagen, bis in die mindestens in die 50er, 60er, wahrscheinlich in die 70er Jahre, war das alles weitestgehend analogtechnisch. Das heißt, man hatte Spulen, Kondensatoren, Schwingkreise, Filter und sonstige Komponenten in der analogen Elektronik und hat damit eben Kommunikation gemacht. Die Kommunikation war auch meistens, also die eigentlichen Daten waren analog. Das heißt, man hatte eben AM Radio, also amplitude moduliertes Radio. Man hatte, so wie es bei der Mittelwelle zum Einsatz kommt, beispielsweise beim Kurzwellenfunk, man hat frequenzmodulierte Analogsignale, wie eben heute noch das FM Radio, das irgendwie jeder hört, im Auto, zu Hause, sonst irgendwo. Das sind alles analoge Informationen. Dann kam der nächste Schritt, dass man anfängt, digital zu modulieren, das heißt, Daten zu übertragen in digitaler Form, wie die populärste Anwendung davon, wahrscheinlich Wi-Fi letztendlich, also das 802.11 Wireless-Funk-Protokoll, ist wahrscheinlich das am weitesten verweitete digitale Funk-System. Und das sind aber jetzt nur die Daten, die eigentlich in Nutzdaten sind digital. Die eigentlichen Sender und Empfänger können weitestgehend nach wie vor analog aufgebaut sein, also mit konventioneller Elektronik, Analogtechnik. Und bei Software Defined Radio zieht man jetzt eben die Digitaltechnik und damit eben die Software immer weiter Richtung Antenne. Wenn man sich so einen klassischen Funkempfänger anschaut, dann hat man eine Antenne, danach kommt unter Umständen ein Filter, ein Verstärker, vielleicht nochmal ein Filter, ein Demodulator und danach kommen dann vielleicht irgendwann mal die Daten raus. Und man zieht jetzt eben die digitale Welt immer näher an die Antenne bis zu einem Punkt, wo man dann tatsächlich nur noch eine Antenne hat, einen Eingangsverstärker, Analog-Digital-Wander, und dann hat man digitale Daten und die kann man mit Computer-Rechnern bearbeiten und kann sämtliche weiteren Schritte in dem ganzen Prozess in Software handhaben.
Das heißt, man redet von einer Hardware, die einfach nichts anderes mehr macht, als eigentlich nur ein analoges Signal, also eine Funkwelle zu erzeugen, was auch immer dann in dieser Funkwelle kodiert ist. Davon reden wir.
Das ist die Sende-Seite, ja.
Ja, ok. Und auf der Empfangsseite entsprechend kommt die Funkwelle an und wird aber auch dort schon von Software in Empfang genommen.
Richtig, ja. Also vielleicht nochmal zum Vergleich. Wo ist jetzt der Unterschied zwischen, ich habe mein FM-Radio und schließe über Chinschpucks meine Soundkarte an, habe danach digitale Audioinformation. Das ist also nicht Software-Defined Radio. Da ist der ganze Empfänger analog und nur am Schluss die eigentlichen Nutzdaten kommen immer noch analog raus und dann wandel ich die digital und kann dann vielleicht sowas wie RDS dekodieren oder so, was ja da auch als digitale Information enthalten ist. Software-Defined Radio macht jetzt aus, dass die Digitalisierung, also die Wandlung von dem Analog zum Digital ganz nahe bei der Antenne basiert und dass das, was man digitalisiert, eben das eigentliche Funksignal ist oder sehr nahe dem eigentlichen Funksignal. Das heißt also, wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel FM-Radio mit, keine Ahnung, 100 MHz empfangen möchte, dann würde man einfach einen sehr schnellen analog-digital-Wander nehmen, der beispielsweise diese 100 MHz wegsamplen kann, also mit 200 Megasamples, also man brauchte immer die doppelte Sampling-Frequenz, und hat dann eine Unmenge an Daten und kann aus diesen Daten dann letztendlich das Audiosignal herausrechnen, ohne dass man irgendwas in Hardware noch braucht. Also es ist einfach echt die Antenne und der analog-digital-Wandler. Und wir kommen dann später noch dazu, ich habe auch solche Hardware eben selber zu Hause, und da kann man einfach wirklich einen Meter langen Draht reinstecken und hat dann sozusagen einen Meter langen Draht an dem analog-digital-Wandler und kann damit Radio hören.
Noch mal so zum Verständnis, wo wir gerade bei den Gleichnissen sind. Etwas, woran ich jetzt auch sofort denke, ist natürlich so ein Datenmodem. Auch diese Datenmodems machen ja erstmal auch nichts anderes als digitale Daten übertragen oder ein analoges Medium, in dem Fall halt ein Telefonsystem. Auch da sind ja die Modems immer pfiffiger geworden, um auch da noch sozusagen Geschwindigkeit rauszuholen, bis hin zu den 56 Kilobit, die zuletzt erzeugt werden, die ja sozusagen nur noch darauf auf der Annahme, dass auf der anderen Seite ein digitales Telefonnetz ist, überhaupt noch funktionieren, weil eigentlich so viel die Trägerfrequenz nicht hergeben würde. Aber da kam jetzt so diese Technik, von der wir reden, noch nicht zum Einsatz, oder?
Nein, also man kann gar sagen nein, weil erstens Modems kein Radio machen, damit kann es kein Software-Defined-Radio sein, weil es kabelgebundene Kommunikation.
Ja, aber man kann ja mit keinem Radio machen, man kann ja eine Podcast mitmachen.
Nein, das ist keine Funkkommunikation, die da stattfindet. Das geht über einen Kabelanschluss, nicht über Funkwellen.
Aber es sind doch analoge Frequenzen. Ob die in die Luft fliegen oder durch einen Kabel, ist doch eigentlich egal, oder?
Jein. Also der Hintergrund, was jetzt technisch logischer nachzuvollziehen ist als der formale Ablehnungsgrund meiner ersten Nein-Answort, juristisch, ist...
Was sich so viel mit GP-Wahl-Lashions beschäftigt.
Möglicherweise, ja. Der zweite technisch sinnvollere Grund ist sozusagen, dass man da von Basisbandkommunikation spricht. Also das heißt, die Information wird im Basisband, das heißt 0 bis, was weiß ich, 50, 100, 150 Kilohertz übertragen. Also sozusagen ohne, dass eine Modulation stattfindet, ohne, dass man in einem Funkband kommuniziert. Ja, also es ist ja so, dass bei jedem Funk-Sender oder Empfänger man einmal das sogenannte Basisband hat, also gehen wir zum analogen Radio, da verstehen es die Leute noch eher, oder es ist leichter zu erklären, wo man wirklich Audio-, also Schallwellen hat, die sich von 0 bis 20.000 Schwingungen pro Sekunde eben in Herz ausgezückt bewegen. Und die kann ich jetzt aber nicht direkt über Funk senden. Ich kann nicht von 0 bis 20 Kilohertz Funk das im Basisband senden, das funktioniert nicht. Sondern man muss diese Information nehmen und muss sie auf eine viel höhere Frequenz, auf eine andere Welle aufmodulieren. Auf die Trägerfrequenz. Richtig. Und diese modulierte Trägerfrequenz ist dann eben in irgendeinem Funkband zu Hause in einem bestimmten Frequenzbereich, wie zum Beispiel diese 100 MHz beim FM-Radio. Und dieser Schritt findet eben einfach nicht statt bei den Modems. Und deswegen fehlt da das. Die Technologie, dass man sehr viel mit digitaler Signalverarbeitung macht in diesen Telefonmodems und dass man auch natürlich mit Analog-Digital-Wandeln und so weiter arbeitet, das ist alles im Grunde das Gleiche in klein. Das ist schon richtig, aber es ist trotzdem schon noch ein sehr großer Schritt hin zum Software-Defined-Radio.
Aber DSPs hast du jetzt angesprochen, das war ja schon so diese erste Versoftverisierung von dem ganzen Encoding.
Ja, es ist einfach so, dass diese sogenannten modernen digitalen Modulationsverfahren, also wir hatten ja schon im Prozess der Modulation das Aufbringen eines Basisband-Signals auf eine Trägerfrequenz in einem bestimmten Funkband, dass da dieser große Durchbruch dann kam. Ich sagte ja, bis in die 70er hinein war das alles eigentlich mehr oder weniger unverändert. Die gleiche Technologie, man hat natürlich Miniaturisiert, Transistor anstatt Röhren und so weiter und so weiter, aber so ein Quantensprung war da nicht der Fall. Und irgendwann ist man in der Mathematik weitergekommen und dann eben auch durch die Mikroprozessoren und die digitalen Signalprozessoren als Spezialgruppe davon war man in der Lage, quasi angewandte Mathematik zu tun, weil nichts anderes ist als digitale Signalverarbeitung. Man hat da alle möglichen Wellen und man kann die in Funktionen beschreiben und man kann transformieren zwischen bestimmten Räumen. Also, Foyer-Transformationen kennt ja jeder beispielsweise. Und solche Dinge. Und man kann dadurch außerordentlich präzise diese Wellen manipulieren, wie man es mit analoge Hardware überhaupt nicht machen könnte. Und auch kleinere Variationen in diesem Wellengeflecht erkennen auf der Empfangsseite. Das ist also mit Analogtechnik einfach nicht machbar. Also jeder, der so ein bisschen, sei es im Audiobereich, mal was von DSP-Technologie gehört hat, ein ganz wichtiges Anwendungsfeld sind Filter. Also wer eine Frequenzweiche oder einen Filter eben für den Audiobereich haben will und baut das analog auf, wenn man dann, also ein Filter wird in der Regel durch die sogenannte Flankensteilheit, also wie genau dieses Filter trennt zwischen den beiden Dingen, die ich filtern möchte und wenn ich das in Analogtechnik mache, dann ist das ein unglaublicher Schaltungsaufwand, um sogenannte Filterhöherordnungen zu erzeugen, die also eine sehr steile Flanke zwischen den beiden Bereichen haben und mit einem digitalen Signalprozessor oder überhaupt in der digitalen Welt absolut leicht. Also da kann ich beliebig steilflanke Filter irgendwie bauen mit ganz eigenartigen Charakteristiken. Das ist alles nur eine Frage, dass das Rechenaufwand, den ich reinstecken will, und der ist gar nicht mal so hoch.
Das heißt, mit den Softwaremethoden, die dann Mitte der 70er Jahre aufkamen?
Da bin ich jetzt kein Historiker in dem...
Das ist für meinen Geschmack so...
Na, ich dege davon aus, dass... Also zunächst muss man natürlich immer auch sehen, wo die Dinge herkommen und ich vermute, also ich bin jetzt tatsächlich überfragt. Aber ich denke, dass auf jeden Fall die mathematischen Grundlagen länger klar sind und die praktischen Implikationen würde ich in die 70er-Jahre packen, in der Tat.
Okay, sind wir jetzt bei Weltraumtechnik?
Das kann ich nicht sagen, ich weiß nicht, was...
Aber sicherlich im militärischen Forschungsbereich.
Das durchaus.
So oder so, ohne konkrete Kenntnisse zu haben. Da muss ich gerade mal überlegen, inwieweit es hier noch sinnvoll ist, wirklich jetzt die Grundlagen des Funks auszurollen. Da kann man es jetzt sicherlich beliebig übertreiben. Ist auch nicht gerade meine Stärke, das sage ich mal dazu. Aber was ich noch nicht ganz verstanden habe, ist jetzt sozusagen wirklich der Unterschied. Also am Anfang ist alles analog. Dann geht man her und ersetzt einzelne Komponenten durch Software. Trotzdem bleibt ja Hardware über. Was ist denn sozusagen, wenn ich von einer vollständigen analogen Radio-Schaltung ausgehe? Und jetzt setzt dieser erste Prozess ein, den du gerade beschrieben hast. Was ist sozusagen das Erste, was wegfällt? Und was wird als nächstes weggefressen, bis wir wirklich zu etwas kommen, was Software Defined Radio heißen kann?
Na gut, also beim wirklich analogen Radio, da habe ich einen komplett analog aufgebauten Empfänger. Man nehme jetzt zum Beispiel einen ganz normalen Radio-Empfänger und hat eben, wie in meinem Eingangsbeispiel, eine Soundkarte angeschlossen. Da ist in dem Radio-Empfänger noch nichts digital. Da kommt ein analoges Signal raus und das wird dann digitalisiert. Und dann kann ich irgendwie mit den Daten anfangen zu rechnen. Der nächste Schritt ist sicherlich der Wegfall des Demodulators. Das heißt, wenn man sich Radio-Empfänger anschaut, da ist jetzt eben das Problem mit den Grundlagen. Da spielen in der Regel mehrere Frequenzen eine Rolle. Es gibt zum einen diese Trägerfrequenz. Gehen wir wieder auf das 100 MHz-Beispiel. Dann gibt es die sogenannten Basisband. Das ist jetzt bei Radio eben 0 bis 20 Kilohertz oder 15 Kilohertz.
Also bei Sprache.
Bei Sprache, ja. Ich nehme jetzt immer das Beispiel von analogem Radio, so wie es jeder kennt.
Radio ist jetzt wirklich ein extrem doppelt- und dreifachdeutiger Begriff in diesem Podcast. Deswegen gehen wir jetzt mal hier von dem Sprachfrequenzbereich.
Genau, von dem ganz normalen FM-Radio im UKW-Bereich.
Das, was Sie jetzt gerade hören.
Das heißt, da sind aber in der Regel noch mehrere Frequenzen in so einem Empfänger drin. Und zwar sind es sogenannte Zwischenfrequenzen. Das heißt, diese 100 Megahertz, die werden nicht direkt demoduliert und dann kommen diese 0 bis 20 Kilohertz raus. Das wäre ein sogenannter Direct-Conversion-Empfänger, wo man das direkt tut. Das ist eine relativ moderne Erscheinung. Üblicherweise hat man da Zwischenfrequenzen bei Consumer-Geräten eine. Das heißt, es wird von diesem hohen Signal, also diese 100 Megahertz, wird erst mal ein sogenanntes Mischen betrieben. Das heißt, das Signal wird heruntergemischt auf eine tiefe Frequenz, sogenannte Zwischenfrequenz, und dann von dort aus demoduliert. Das hat mehrere Vorteile, aber da möchte ich jetzt wirklich nicht noch weiter ins Detail gehen. Aber ich will nur sagen, dass man sozusagen, also man hat in diesem sogenannten Super-Hat-Empfänger in sich dann dieses Prinzip, also man hat die Trägerfrequenz 100 Megahertz, hat eine Zwischenfrequenz, lass es keine Ahnung, 5 Megahertz sein, und hat danach, also Trägerfrequenz, Mischer, Zwischenfrequenz, Demodulator, Basisband. Das ist so die Kette von Eingang zum Ausgang. Und der erste Schritt ist dann, dass man eben diesen Demodulator weglässt und die Zwischenfrequenz direkt analog digital wandelt. Das heißt, diese 5 Megahertz sind im Beispiel. Und dann hat man eben diese, wenn es 5 Megahertz sind, muss man eben wieder nach Nyquist 10 Megahertz mindestens Samplingrate haben und hat dann also eben 10 Millionen numerische Werte, die aus dem analog digital wandeln, da rauskommen pro Sekunde und die muss man dann in den Software werkeln.
Also das wäre jetzt sozusagen der erste Schritt. Man ersetzt diesen Demodulator, geht direkt an diese Zwischenfrequenz ran. Was fällt da so konkret an Bauteilen weg?
Das kommt sehr stark darauf an, welches Verfahren moduliert wird. Da ist es verschwindend gering, da macht das kaum Sinn. Der einfachste Fall wäre jetzt AM, also Mittelwelle-Radio oder so. Da ist im Prinzip eine Diode, um das zu demodulieren. Das heißt, da spart man sich einen einzigen Halbleiter. Das ist irgendwie witzlos. Bei Frequenzmutationen, also eben dem UKW-Radio, da wird es schon ein bisschen komplizierter. Aber es sind doch noch sehr einfache, billige, analoge Komponenten, die da wegfallen. Der wahre Grund, warum man das macht, ist nicht, weil man irgendwie 2 Cent Bauteile spart. Weil der digitale Signalprozessor ist in der Regel teurer, den man dann als Ersatz dafür braucht. Sondern der wahre Grund sind eben genau diese digitalen Modulationsverfahren. Da ist es eben so, dass wenn man von AM und FM weggeht Richtung digitale Modulationsverfahren, da gibt es also so Kürzel wie QPSK und GMSK und PSK, QAM, was auch immer. Also es gibt unendlich viele verschiedene von diesen digitalen Modulationsverfahren. Und die kann man halt sauber nur dann demodulieren, wenn man das schon in Software tut. Weil da braucht man komplexe Mathematik dazu. Da muss man sehr genaue Feinheiten unterscheiden. Das kann man dann mit analogen Bauteilen gar nicht mehr.
Zur Klärung, diese digitalen Modulationsverfahren bedeuten, man hat sozusagen ein digitales Encoding auf der Strecke. Das heißt, das Radio wird nicht wie bisher analog übertragen, sondern halt digital übertragen. Sprich mit den gängigen Vorteilen, die man dann so hat, dass klanglich das eigentlich alles toller und besser sein soll. Aber wenn da mal wirklich Fehler auftauchen, ist es so ein bisschen wie bei DVB-TV-Gucken. Dann haben wir dann gleich Klötzchen.
Ja, das ist in der Tat richtig.
Also du meinst, der Hauptgrund ist jetzt für diesen ersten Schritt gar nicht mehr Kostenersparnis, sondern dass man überhaupt digital werden kann. Dass man diese Modulationsverfahren effektiv machen kann, die analog nicht so realisieren werden.
Genau. Der Punkt ist, wie so häufig, wenn man anfängt, analoge Dinge durch digitale zu ersetzen, man möchte mehr Daten übertragen auf dem gleichen Frequenzband. Die Frequenzen, die uns zur Verfügung stehen im Funkspektrum, sind begrenzt. Es wird immer enger. Es gibt unglaublich viele Frequenzen, die belegt sind durch traditionelle echte Hörfunk-Radio-Dienste, analoges Fernsehen, digitales Fernsehen, Mobilfunk, Wi-Fi und so weiter und so weiter. Es sind immer mehr Dinge, die angeboten werden und der Raum einer begrenzten Ressource wird immer knapper. Deswegen will man natürlich mehr Daten auf weniger benutzten Frequenzspektren übertragen. Dadurch möchte man möglichst effizient mit der Ressource umgehen. Diese Effizienz wiederum impliziert diese komplexen digitalen Modulationsverfahren, mit denen man sehr viel mehr übertragen kann über den gleichen Kanal.
Also nicht nur bessere Qualität, sondern vor allem auch effizientere Nutzung des Frequenzraums. Jetzt haben wir also quasi den ersten Schritt gemacht. Wir sparen uns also diese letzte Demodulationseinheit, bleibt ja aber immer noch etwas übrig. Inwieweit ist denn das, was übrig bleibt, eigentlich auch an einen bestimmten Frequenzbereich gebunden? Analoge Technik heißt ja auch, dass es für einen bestimmten Frequenzbereich gebaut ist.
Das ist richtig. Das mit dem für einen Frequenzbereich gebaut bedingt sich eben im Wesentlichen durch sogenannte Filter. Das hatte ich ja vorhin schon mal angesprochen. Filter ist also sehr einfach. Es gibt erstmal einen Hochpass oder einen Tiefpass. Es ist nichts anderes, als ich habe irgendwie Frequenzen von sagen wir 0 bis 100 MHz und ich will jetzt aber nur 90 bis 100 haben und den Rest davor will ich irgendwie unterdrücken und verwerfen. Das möchte man deswegen tun, um sozusagen eine Trennscharfe zu bekommen beim Empfang. Man hat eben dieses unendlich breite, na ja nicht unendlich, dieses sehr breite...
Das große Rauschen.
Genau, das große Rauschen der Welt. Und da ist ja alles drin. Da habe ich eben wie gesagt Mobilfunk, Radio, Dienste, Fernsehen, Analog, Digital usw. usw. usw.
Schreie in den Kinder.
Die kommunizieren oder die Schreie sind in der Regel im Audiofrequenzband und nicht im elektromagnetischen Spektrum.
Manche Schreie sind so spitz und schrill, dass man das nicht glauben mag. Ich melde berechtigte Zweifel an. Man hat eine riesige weiße Wolke an Funkmüll. Man möchte das natürlich auf den Kanal, auf das Band beschränken, was man wirklich betrachtet und auch nur demodulieren will.
Richtig. Das ist also wichtig, weil sonst hätte man ja eben diesen ganzen anderen Müll auch dabei. Das funktioniert in der Regel relativ gut, aber es gibt keine hundertprozentige Zinsschärfe. Man kann nicht sagen, das ist nicht digital, das ist Analogtechnik. Das heißt, man hat nicht nur FM-Radio und gar nichts anderes. Den Effekt kennt jeder, legt mal ein GSM-Telefon in der Nähe von einem Radioempfänger. Obwohl das GSM-Telefon bei neunmal so hoher Frequenzarbeit, also bei 900 MHz statt bei 100, wie euer FM-Radio, kriegt ihr trotzdem noch aufgrund des starken Signals eben da Übersprecher rein und habt dann euren Trattattattattat Geräusch.
Ja, ja, sehr beliebt bei Podcast-Aufnahmen.
Genau.
Hast du dein GSM-Telefon schon ausgeschaltet?
Sind in der Diele.
Aha, okay. Ich hab ja UNTS, da können wir das ja nicht präsentieren.
Ja, also sozusagen, 100%ige Trennung gibt's nicht, aber man dämpft eben das restliche Signal und hat dadurch eine Trennscharfe, die man möchte. Und diese Filter, das ist jetzt eben auch wieder was in der Analogtechnik, wo ich gerade schon beschrieben habe, Filter mit hoher Trennscharfe bedürfen sehr hohem schaltungstechnischen Aufwand. Ja, das heißt, jeder, der mal irgendwie Physik hatte und ein bisschen Elektrotechnik, der weiß noch, ah, da gibt's vielleicht so was wie ein LC-Filter oder ein RC-Filter, also wo man zwei Bauteile miteinander kombiniert, Widerstand und Spule oder Kondensator und Spule und so. Und die haben keine Trennscharfe. Das heißt, man braucht dann mindestens irgendwie drei, vier oder so solche Stufen. Das heißt also, wir sprechen dann von so was wie mindestens acht oder noch mehr Bauteile, die da verschalten sind. Das Problem ist auch, dass die unglaublich schwer zu handhaben sind, weil die beeinflussen sich alle gegenseitig, diese Bauteile. Das ist sehr schwierig, die Simulation kann man im Kopf kaum mehr machen. Und dann haben die Bauteile alle Toleranzen, die sich gegenseitig beeinflussen. Am Ende bekommt man selten genau das, was man haben möchte. Und das ist dann fix, dieses Filter, das ist fest. Das ist auf eine bestimmte Frequenz, das kann ich nicht einstellen. Wenn ich das einstellen möchte, dann brauche ich sowas wie Drehkondensatoren oder Spulen, wo man den Kern drehen kann. Sowas kennt man vielleicht von richtig alten Radios, wo diese Plattenkondensatoren, die sich ineinander hineinschieben. Modernere Variante davon macht man damit Kapazitätsdioden statt Kondensator, aber es gibt zwei unterschiedliche Anfangs. Das eine ist hohe Trennscharfe, das andere ist Abstimmbarkeit. Die beiden miteinander vereinbar sind sie nicht wirklich ohne exorbitanten Aufwand. Das heißt, man kann entweder trennscharfe Filter haben oder man kann es abstimmbar haben. Das ist der Grund, warum all die Radioempfänger, die wir so haben, festgelegt sind in einem bestimmten Frequenzbereich. Weil da feste Filter drin sind, die unveränderbar sind, damit sie trennscharfe haben. Und deswegen können wir nicht aus dem Frequenzbereich raus. Da kommt dann eben genau wieder dieser Aha-Effekt mit dem Software Defined Radio. Wie ich schon gesagt habe, da kann man Filter beliebiger Flankensteilheit oder nahezu beliebiger trennscharfe sozusagen in Software schreiben. Und dadurch ist auf einmal, nachdem ich Software natürlich immer verändern kann, habe ich auch die Abstimmbarkeit. Das heißt, auf einmal fällt diese Beschränkung weg und ich habe die Vision eines Empfängers, beim Sender natürlich genauso, der alles empfangen kann. Und ich kann mir beliebiges aus diesem großen Rauschen heraus suchen.
Ich meine, es gibt ja so im Fachhandel, gibt es ja, oder auch bei Konrad.
Das ist schön, dass du den Fachhandel differenzierst von Konrad, das finde ich sehr schön.
Ja, ja, halt so diese, du weißt schon, diese Läden, die halt einmal alles verkaufen oder eben auch irgendwie sich auskennen, da gibt es dann halt so Scanner. Einfach so ein Gerät, sieht so ein bisschen aus, wie so ein überdimensionales Handy. Und die machen ja auch enorme Frequenzbereiche, oder?
Das ist richtig. Also ich habe mir gerade jetzt eben in Taiwan eingekauft. Hast du ihn mit? Nein, dann habe ich nicht mit. So ein kleines handliches Gerät, kleiner als irgendwie die CW-Funkgeräte in meiner Jugend, die man so in der Hand hatte. Also es ist vielleicht noch ein großes Problem.
Aber die gibt es ja schon lange.
Die gibt es lange, das ist richtig.
So, wie machen die denn das mit ihrer Frequenzeinschränkung? Die waren ja sicherlich am Anfang auch weitgehend analog aufgebaut.
Die sind auch nach wie vor analog. Also mir ist nicht bekannt, dass die... Also da ist zwar die Bedienung digital und dass man die Frequenz digital einstellen kann und so weiter, aber ansonsten ist meines Kenntnisstands nach bei den Scanner-Empfängern nach wie vor alles analog. Das heißt, sie haben dann mehrere Empfangseinheiten wahrscheinlich dann für die unterschiedlichen Frequenzbereiche? Umschaltbare Filterbänke ist ein Konzept, was man wahrscheinlich bei dieser hohen Integrierung bei den kleinen, modernen Handgeräten jetzt nicht mehr so einsetzt. Aber das ist sicherlich, wovon man ausgegangen ist oder wo man am Anfang war. Grob macht man das wahrscheinlich immer noch, also dass man, sagen wir mal so 3, 4 vielleicht verschiedene Bereiche hat zur Vorfilterung. Und dann ist es eben so, dass diese Geräte auch eine sehr schlechte Trennschärfe haben. Das reicht halt für vieles. Aber bei diesen Empfängern ist es auch, also bei den Handgeräten ist mir keins bekannt, mit dem man also irgendwelche digitalen Modulationsverfahren empfangen könnte. Es gibt bei den Tischgeräten, gibt es welche, die dann einen Zwischenfrequenzausgang haben oder wo man einen nachrüsten kann, der dann qualitativ so hoch ist, dass man da dann hinterher auch noch die Signale irgendwie nach digital wandeln kann und damit irgendwas anfangen kann. Aber die Anforderungen jetzt bezüglich einfacher AM-FM-Radio-Empfang sind halt relativ gering. Man arbeitet mit großen Sendern, großen Feldstärken, die Entfernungen, die man übrigt, sind nicht so hoch und die Datenrate sozusagen, also die Menge an Informationen pro Energie ist verschwindend gering.
Das heißt, der technische analoge Aufwand, der zu treiben ist, um überhaupt hohe Frequenzen zu empfangen zu können, extrahieren zu können, um sie dann zu bearbeiten, schreit eigentlich nach einer Softwarelösung. Ist die Idee von Software Defined Radio, solche Geräte billiger, flexibler oder kleiner zu machen?
Was die kommerziellen Firmen, die in dem Felde tätig sind, was die sich so davon versprechen, außerhalb des Rüstungsbereichs, wo gerade im Moment in den USA die großen Geldbeutel für Software Defined Radio Projekte geöffnet werden, das kann ich nicht beantworten. Sicherlich, wie ich schon sagte, die Möglichkeit dessen, was man mit Software Defined Radio machen kann, im Endstadium ist wirklich dieser universelle Empfänger oder auch der universelle Sender, der ist noch ein bisschen schwieriger. Aber der universelle Empfänger, dass man wirklich ein Gerät hat, ein Stück Hardware und mit dem kann man dann von Mobiltelefonie über digitales Fernsehen, über RFID, alles, was irgendwo mit Funk arbeitet, mit diesem einen Gerät abdecken. Das Einzige, was man machen muss, ist halt, man startet ein anderes Programm und man kann halt nicht mehrere Dinge gleichzeitig verwenden.
Sozusagen der Personalkomputer für den Funkempfang.
Das ist richtig, ja. Und so wahnsinnig weit weg von dieser Vision sind wir nicht mehr, was die Hardware-Technologie betrifft. Die Kommerzielle, also die Wirtschaft, die im Halbleiter- und Funkumfeld tätig ist, verwendet Software Defined Radio schon auch sehr stark, aber bisher seltenst in diesem Endstadium, wie ich es bezeichnet habe. Das heißt, man geht zwar sehr nahe ran mit der Digitaltechnik an die Antenne und eliminiert sehr viele analoge Bauteile, aber das dann dort meistens eher aus weniger, wie soll ich sagen, kundenfreundlichen Gründen, sondern eher weil man Toleranzen baut. Also Digitaltechnik hat ja immer den Vorteil, entweder es geht oder es geht nicht. Analogtechnik ist immer so...
Was auch Vorteile haben kann.
Hat Vorteile, Nachteile. Aber wenn du Hersteller bist, der Dinge verkaufen will, also halbleiter, dann ist es sehr angenehm, wenn du sicher sagen kannst, naja, das funktioniert, und das ist innerhalb der Spezifikation, das tut. Und sicher sagen kannst, das ist außerhalb, das ist Schnott, den muss ich einstampfen. Das heißt, da ergibt sich ja eine Motivation. Ein anderer wichtiger Grund ist, je mehr ich hoch integriere und digital arbeite, umso weniger, also analoge Schaltungen im Funkbereich oder generell mit Schwingkreisen haben so dieses Problem, man muss sie abstimmen. Das heißt, während der Fertigung muss man da dann am Schluss, eben weil die Bauteile aller Toleranzen haben, muss man an der Umstände hier und da ein einstellbares Bauteil einbauen, was dann in der Fertigungsstraße am Schluss abgestimmt wird und womit man dann das Ganze eben ausgleicht und letztendlich dafür sorgt, dass es am richtigen Frequenzband läuft und so. Und diese ganzen abstimmenden Geschichten, die will man nicht haben, das kostet nur Zeit irgendwie in der Fertigung. Die variablen Bauteile sind teuer. Mittlerweile macht man dann elektronische Bauteile, die variabel sind, also sowas wie digitale Potentiometer und Ähnliches oder Kapazitation. Aber letztendlich sozusagen der ganze Aufwand, alles, was man irgendwie in Software machen kann, hat den Vorteil, erstens man macht das einmal und man kann das in der Regel mit sehr viel unterschiedlicher Hardware verwenden. Man kann es beliebig kopieren, man kann das Bug fixen, nachdem es ausgeliefert ist usw. Die ganzen Dinge, die uns eben bekannt sind aus der Softwarebranche, die für die Hardwarebranche halt irgendwie sehr neu sind. Und dadurch kann man halt schneller, ja, faster time to market und diese ganzen Dinge, die halt irgendwie in der Industrie zählen. Also da, wie gesagt, dieses mehr oder weniger altruistische, würde ich schon fast sagen, Ziel des universellen Empfängers, mit dem jedermann alles empfangen kann. Das interessiert natürlich die Wirtschaft nachrangig, würde ich sagen. Weil letztlich können sie da ja unter Umständen nur weniger Geräte verkaufen, was man dadurch kompensieren kann, dass man profitäre Software für unterschiedliche Frequenzminder lizenzieren könnte usw. Aber ich denke, klar sind sie mit den Businessmodellen auch noch nicht so ganz am Ende der Fahnenstange.
Also, sprich Software Defined Radio verspricht, Fertigungsprozesse einfacher zu machen, überhaupt generell auch einfach solche Empfängergeräte, aber auch theoretische Sendergeräte, reden wir sicherlich auch nochmal drüber. Ja, soweit zu vereinfachen, dass man das eben alles per Software macht, von daher eine höhere Verfügbarkeit, Verlässlichkeit an der Stelle erwarten kann, so denn die anderen Komponenten überhaupt funktionieren und vor allem natürlich auch die Software, was nochmal ein Thema für sich ist.
Aber die kann man updaten, auch wenn es schon beim Kunden ist.
Die kann man updaten und die muss man dann wahrscheinlich auch updaten. Genau, da haben wir dann auch wieder schöne Security-Implications. Bevor wir aber darauf vielleicht nochmal kommen, ich wollte das nochmal so kurz abschließen, weil wir im Prinzip erläutert haben, wie war es vorher, also wie musste man es vorher machen, was sind da die Probleme. Und jetzt kommen wir also zu so einem Punkt, es gibt Software Defined Radio, wir verstehen einfach ein System so, da ist irgendwie eine Antenne dran, das angelt sich so die elektromagnetischen Wellen aus der Luft, führt sie in ein System. Was muss denn jetzt noch in Hardware konkret gemacht werden, bis die Software zum Spielen kommt?
Das hängt in der Regel davon ab, wie viel Geld man zur Verfügung hat und welche Frequenzen man empfangen möchte. Der Punkt ist einfach...
Fragen wir doch mal, wir würden so im Handybereich agieren, oder ist das ein schlechtes Beispiel für einen Start?
Der Punkt ist sozusagen... In der Regel würde ich sagen, bei wahrscheinlich 90% der Software-Defined-Radio-Systeme, die im Umlauf sind im Moment, keiner weiß ja, dass die Wi-Fi-Karte in seinem Rechner Software-Defined-Radio intern verwendet, ist es so, dass man tatsächlich eine Antenne hat, einen Eingangsverstärker, einen Eingangsfilter, einen Starren für das Band, das man empfängt, und danach dann eine Stufe hat, wo man runter mischt auf eine andere Frequenz, also dieses Mischen mit der Zwischenfrequenz. Und das Ergebnis dessen, jetzt höre ich aber doch irgendwas.
Das heißt, das ist dein Telefon, das eigentlich in der Diele sein sollte?
Das ist in der Tat mein Telefon.
Da haben wir es auch schon gleich, unsere Frequenzeinstrahlung.
Das heißt, wo war ich stehen geblieben? Das wird gemischt, die Zwischenfrequenz, richtig. Die nennt man dann unter Umständen nicht mehr Zwischenfrequenz, aber letztlich einmal Mischen und danach Analog-Digital-Wandlung. Das ist dann alles in Software. Das ist also das, was man macht. Man kann einen Schritt weitergehen und tatsächlich nur noch die Antenne, gegebenenfalls Verstärker, und dann Analog-Digital-Wandler machen. Das hängt im Wesentlichen davon ab, wie viel Geld man eben für diesen Analog-Digital-Wandler ausgibt, weil die Geschwindigkeit, also wie viele Samples pro Sekunde der machen kann, direkt proportional mit dem Preis zusammenhängt, den man irgendwie dafür lönen muss.
Genau, weil Software-Defined Radio heißt ja, man kann alles in Software machen, aber man muss auch alles in Software machen. Das heißt, man braucht auch die notwendige Prozessorpower, um überhaupt so viele Samples pro Sekunde bearbeiten zu können. Deswegen ist das eine Sache, die jetzt erst kommt, weil in den stromsparenden Geräten natürlich auch nicht unbedingt so viel Power zur Verfügung steht, wie man das jetzt von Computer, also von Desktopcomputern gewohnt ist oder sonstigen Maschinen. Jetzt hast du gesagt, Software-Defined Radio wird heute schon verwendet, zum Beispiel in WLAN-Systemen.
Ja, das ist wahrscheinlich eines der populären Beispiele. Es ist so ein bisschen auch die Frage, es gibt Leute, das sind so die SDR, Software-Defined Radio Puristen, die sagen, naja, alles, wo irgendwas noch in Analogtechnik gemacht wird, jenseits der Verstärkung, also wo gemischt wird oder irgendwas zur Frequenz verändern, das ist kein Software-Defined Radio. Das ist jetzt meiner Meinung nach nicht die allgemeine Auffassung des Ganzen. Aber ich denke eben, wo dieser eine Schritt nach unten, dieses eine Mischen auf eine andere Frequenz, ist jetzt gemäß meiner etwas lockeren oder auch der weitläufigen Definition in Ordnung. Und da kommt man also schon eben bei modernen Satellitentunern für digitales Fernsehen, da ist das auch so. Da wird quasi, da sind das sogenannte Zero IF Conversion, also Direct Conversion, das heißt, man setzt direkt von der Frequenz runter, also von der hohen Frequenz auf eine ganz niedrige, ohne Zwischenfrequenz, und danach kommt der analoge Digital-Mann. Ja, also ohne Zwischenfrequenz. IF ist Intermediate Frequencing, das ist die Zwischenfrequenz, und Zero IF heißt also ohne Zwischenfrequenz, was aber auch Synonym ist zu Direct Conversion, also da hat direkte Umsetzungen, also von der hohen Frequenz, von der Trägerfrequenz auf die...
Das heißt, ob man jetzt sozusagen direkt an die Antenne geht oder noch analoge Hardware hat, die Zwischenfrequenz rausklamm, büsert, das ist letzten Endes eine Abwägung, eine Geldfrage.
Richtig, ja.
Und wenn man irgendwie die Processing-Power hat, dann lässt man das irgendwie auch weg, aber wenn man irgendwie mit weniger Processing-Power daran muss, investiert man unter Umständen nochmal in die Hardware, vor allem wenn man da sozusagen eh weiß, auf welchen Frequenzbereich man sich bezieht. Weil das ist ja eigentlich für die meisten Geräte klar. Also man weiß ja, WLAN hat halt irgendwie seinen 2,4 Gigahertz, GSM hat seine, naja, drei Bänder immerhin.
Vier.
Sind's vier jetzt? Oh, ah stimmt, Quad-Band. Was ist denn das Vierte?
Du hast 850, was USA spezifisch niedrig ist, hast 900, was so das Eingangsfrequenzband war, und dann gibt's 1800 und 1900. Bei 1900 auch wieder eher USA und 1800 eher wieder Europa.
Ja, Europa ist nur 900 und 1800, ne? Okay, vier, macht ja auch den Aufwand.
Ja, und bei UMTS haben wir glaube ich auch schon wieder drei oder so inzwischen. Das heißt also in so einem modernen Allbandempfänger hat man tatsächlich irgendwie sieben Frequenzbänder in seinem Telefon drin. Und dann muss man ja noch dazu sagen, dass Sende- und Empfangsfrequenzen bei diesen Mobilfunkstandards immer getrennt sind. Das heißt also man hat irgendwie sieben Empfangs- und sieben Sendebänder. Also das ist schon hochkomplex, was da abgeht. Und auch dort geht der Trend natürlich Richtung Software-defined Radio. Also die modernen Chipsetze für Mobilfunkgeräte gehen da auch sehr weit in dem Hinblick. Also ich habe schon welche gesehen, wo der Empfänger für UMTS gleichzeitig auch GPS empfängt, sozusagen. Weil das nicht ganz so weit weg ist vom Frequenzband her. Und man schaltet dann quasi einen anderen Filter davor, weil GPS ist ein extrem schwaches Signal, da braucht man sehr spezielle Filter. Wenn ich das jetzt noch wüsste, 1400, 1500, 1300, irgendwo.
Warte mal, ich frage mal hier die Alwissene Müllhalle. Aber warte mal, UMTS-Frequenz, wenn ich das hier gerade richtig nachgeschlagen habe. Downlink 2100 MHz, also 211 bis 217. Also 2,11 GHz bis 2,17 GHz. Das müsste ja dann auch sozusagen der GPS-Frequenzbereich sein, oder?
Na, nicht ganz.
Was ist denn das hier? Vielleicht sollte ich in der englischen Wikipedia nicht unbedingt nach einem deutschen Wort suchen. Willkommen beim Live-Wikipedia-Cast bei Chaosradio Express.
Also es gibt unterschiedliche, ich sehe hier gerade 1,5, 1,2, 1,3.
Ja, und nochmal 1,3, nochmal 1,1. Ja, das würde ich jetzt sozusagen einer These ein bisschen widersprechen.
Nein, nein, also ich sagte ja, da wird ein anderes Filter vorgeschalten. Ja, bei GPS spezielle, aber so der analog-digital-Wander, da gibt es ja auch bestimmte Parameter wie Dynamikbereich und Wandbreite, also Sampling-Frequenz und so weiter. Ja, da reichen die Parameter halt aus, dass man da dann das umschaltet.
Das heißt, man holt sich zwei verschiedene Bänder raus, aber man kann mit der Hardware, die man sonst zur Verfügung hat, beide im Prinzip bearbeiten.
Genau, und das die restlichen Empfänger, also zum Beispiel der UMTS-Empfänger, also nur für die Empfangsseite und der GPS-Empfänger, sondern halt zwei unterschiedliche Stücke Software, die auf dem Prozessor in einem Gerät laufen.
Aha, das könnte natürlich die Kosten für so ein UMTS plus GPS-Telefon doch nochmal erheblich senken.
Das ist so eine Frage, da bin ich mir nicht sicher, ob das erheblich ist, weil in der Regel werden halt diese ganzen, ich weiß nicht, was bei GPS ist, aber bei vielen dieser Funkstandards, insbesondere bei dem Mobilfunk, ist das der größte Anteil eigentlich inzwischen Patentlizenzen. Und die fallen halt an, egal ob du das jetzt in Hardware oder Software implementierst, zumindest in großen Jurisdiktionen dieser Welt.
Müssen wir noch ein bisschen warten, bis es billiger wird.
Ja, also das sehe ich auch noch große, wie soll ich sagen, graue Wolken auf uns zukommen, was mit den ganzen Patenten ist.
Weil es so viele gibt in diesem Bereich, dass man sich irgendwann nur noch, wahrscheinlich kostet die Hardware irgendwann gar nichts mehr.
Nein, es ist halt einfach, zumindest in Europa haben wir ja noch, muss man fast wieder sagen, eine Zerrennung zwischen Patente in Hardware ja, Patente in Software als solche nein. Und jetzt haben wir auf einmal Dinge, wo zum Beispiel ein Patent geschrieben wurde für etwas, was in Hardware gemacht wurde, und jetzt wird es auf einmal in Software gemacht. Ist das jetzt noch gültig oder nicht? Wie viele Gerichte können sich da wieder zu überstreiten? Ist es dann Software als solche? Nein, weil es ist ja in Verbindung mit Hardware und naja, da...
Die einzige wirklich sichere Branche ist die Branche der Juristen. Die haben immer Konjunktur.
Ja, vor allem in diesem IT-Recht und das Recht kommt einfach nicht hinterher. Aber gut, lass uns nicht zu weit abschweifen.
Nein, nein. Das ist nicht unser Thema heute. Das Thema ist Software Defined Radio. Und ja, jetzt muss ich noch mal ein bisschen nachdenken. Bisher hatten wir ja da doch halbwegs Linien. Da sollten wir doch mal versuchen, die auch beizubehalten. Jetzt bin ich aber selber ein bisschen aus der Spur. Also wir haben festgestellt, es gibt Geräte, die das nutzen. WLAN-Karten hatten wir sozusagen als Beispiel. Die machen jetzt nicht Software Defined Radio in der Hardcore SM-Variante mit irgendwie Antenne und dann gleich Software dahinter, sondern es gibt da Abstufung. Meistens ist es so, dass man diesen Geräten schon noch eine analoge Komponente spendiert, die halt die Frequenzen so weit erstmal rausfiltert und auch für die Demolation notwendige Zwischenfrequenz vorkaut und dann stürzt sich die Software auf den Rest. Richtig. Sind WLAN-Karten jetzt so die einzigen Beispiele? Sicherlich nicht. Wie sieht denn das so bei Telefonen aus?
Na, wir hatten ja gerade schon angesprochen, ich kenne eben eine Familie von Chipsetzen, der Firma Qualcomm, die hatten ja auch erst schöne Patentstreitigkeiten mit. Aber ja, wo dieses GPS und UMTS eben quasi in einem...
Okay, das ist jetzt ein Chip, aber die anderen machen das alle noch nicht. Ist das jetzt der Trend irgendwie? Also finden wir uns da jetzt sozusagen gerade im Übergang, dass eigentlich alles nur noch auf Software-Define Radio hinausläuft?
Gut, das ist jetzt wieder so eine... Also es gibt da ja sehr viele Abstufungen. Wie viel macht man digital, wie viel noch analog und wo zieht man jetzt die Grenze. Aber es ist schon generell der Trend zu beobachten, dass immer mehr in Software gemacht wird. Und so, ja, Software-Define Radio findet in immer mehr Geräten statt. Was ich noch ein schönes Beispiel finde, das ich gerade schon mal kurz erwähnt, sind die Satelliten-Empfänger oder auch DVB-T-Empfänger. Inzwischen gibt es auch die, die mit Software-Define Radio arbeiten, aber DVB-S ist mir bekannt auch noch als... Eine Geschichte. Ja, das heißt, da hat man eben seine... Bei Satelliten ist es noch ein bisschen komplizierter, weil da in der Regel schon mal von 10 Gigahertz auf irgendwie 1 bis 2 Gigahertz in dem LNB an der Schüssel umgesetzt wird und dann geht es zum Receiver. Und da ist dann so ein Direct-Conversion wieder drin, der das in 0 bis 25 Megahertz umwandelt. Und dahinter ist unser analog-digital-Wandler und da ist das dann wieder in Software.
Aber grundsätzlich kann man feststellen, es wird nicht mehr analoge Technik, es wird einfach zunehmend weniger. Die Frage ist, wo die Grenze ist, aber sie schiebt sich einfach langsam weg, sodass man irgendwann mehr und mehr auf Systeme hinausläuft, wo man wirklich dieses Antenne an Software, diesen Zustand sozusagen erreicht.
Das ist im Moment jetzt noch relativ selten, in dieser Fuhrenform zu beobachten, aber es gibt auch da schon Geräte dafür, die aber meines Erkenntnisses nach eher im enthousiasten und technisch-wissenschaftlichen Bereich zu finden sind. Aber geben tut es das schon als Technologie.
Ja, aber jetzt wollen wir ja hier nicht über Geräte reden, an die man nicht rankommt und die irgendwo gefertigt werden und die man in der Regel nur benutzt, sondern uns geht es ja hier eigentlich auch sehr viel mehr ums Selber machen. Und jetzt hast du dich nicht ohne Grund mit diesen Grundlagen beschäftigt. Du hast eine ganze Menge gearbeitet mit einem Toolset, das bekannt ist unter dem Namen GNU Radio. Das gibt es auch schon eine Weile. Was ist GNU Radio?
Ja, GNU Radio ist eine Software-Suite, kann man sagen. Also ein System aus unterschiedlichen Software-Komponenten zum Betreiben von Software-Defined-Radio auf Standard-PCs. Das heißt, das ist quasi eine Sammlung von Bausteinen, die bestimmte Funktionen implementieren, die bestimmte Algorithmen implementieren. Diese Bauklötze kann man sich in dieser Software zusammen stricken und die dann loslassen auf digitale Signale. Der Unterschied im Wesentlichen zu den vielen kommerziellen Applikationen ist, dass das alles auf einem normalen PC-Prozessor läuft. Das heißt, das ist eine Software, ein Anwendungsprogramm, das kann man unter Mac OS, Windows, Linux, BSD, sonst irgendwie betreiben. Man braucht dann eine Signalquelle, da kommen wir später noch dazu, weil gehen wir mal davon aus, wir haben bereits ein digitales Signal vorliegen, und dann kann ich da einzelne Blöcke drauf werfen, also sowas wie einen FM-Demodulator oder einen Filter, oder ich kann mir das wie ein Art Oszillogramm darstellen lassen, das Signal, oder ein Frequenzspektrum, eine Folie-Analyse oder derartiges. Und der Vorteil, also die Frage ist sozusagen, warum macht man das jetzt auf dem Standard-PC? Der ist ja gar nicht optimiert für digitale Signalverarbeitung, da gibt es ja digitale Signalprozessoren. Und das ist eben genau der Grund, warum man es auf dem PC macht, eben damit man keine spezielle Hardware braucht für diese ganze Bearbeitung. Das ist furchtbar ineffizient und energieverschwendend und was noch, das dort zu tun. Aber eben jeder hat so ein PC rumstehen und nur Radio selbst ist frei Software, das heißt jeder kann sich die auch installieren. Das heißt also, das einzige Problem ist noch, woher bekomme ich diese digitalen Daten? Aber danach ist es eben dort möglich, auch die Programmierung von Standard-PC-Software, da gibt es wahrscheinlich Millionen von Leuten, die sich damit auskennen, also die in der Lage sind, einen mathematischen Algorithmus oder irgendwelche Dinge in einem Anwendungsprogramm zu implementieren, das zu ausführen zu bringen. Wohingegen die Leute, die das auf einem digitalen Signalprozessor können, ist halt extrem beschränkt. Und da gibt es auch ganz viel verschiedene und deswegen eben die Idee, wir machen das auf dem PC.
GNU Radio ist ja nichts Neues, das Projekt gibt es mittlerweile seit 10 Jahren, ist so aus der FSF-Szene heraus geboren worden. Also John Gilmour hat das, glaube ich, ursprünglich mal finanziert und wurde vor allem von Eric Blossom entwickelt, der übrigens auch schon mal Gast bei Chaosradio Express war. Ich habe ein Interview mit ihm geführt, was gleich in zwei Feats aufgetaucht ist, hier bei Chaosradio Express war es die Nummer 12. Eigentlich gehört es zu Chaosradio Express International, die Nummer 3. Ich habe damals noch einen beiden Feats gehabt, das mache ich jetzt nicht mehr. Sehr schöne Sendung, da geht es allerdings mehr um ihn. Und das mit GNU Radio ist ein bisschen nebenbei, aber bringt auch rüber, was für ein angenehmer Mensch er ist. Er ist ja auch Dauergast bei uns auf den Camps und auch häufig auf dem Kongress anzutreffen. Das nur so nebenbei, wen das interessiert, kann er auch nochmal reinhören. Wie ist jetzt diese Software aufgebaut? Wie muss ich das jetzt verstehen? Hat das irgendwie eine GUI-Komponente oder ist das irgendwie komplett alles auf der Kommandozahle? Ist das jetzt nur für Programmierer oder gibt es da auch fertige Tools, die man machen kann? Und wie kann ich das anwenden? Was wäre so ein einfaches Beispiel, wie man aus dem System Nutzen ziehen kann?
Zunächst zu der Struktur der Software. Ich habe ja schon von diesen Bauklötzen, also den sogenannten Building Blocks, innerhalb GNU Radio gesprochen. Das sind also objektorientiert entwickelte Blöcke, die normalerweise in C++ implementiert sind. Teilweise aber auch in Python. Diese Building Blocks, die werden dann miteinander verknüpft, in der Regel durch einen Python-Script. Das heißt, diese Building Blocks, ich habe gesagt C++, aber so Dinge wie zum Beispiel eine FFT, eine Foyer-Transformation, die sind dann schon, da wird dann wieder eine Bibliothek benutzt, die das in Assembler möglichst effizient auf dem wirkenden Prozessor ausführt. Das heißt also, man versucht schon auf der einen Seite die Effizienz der Algorithmen zu haben durch optimierte Implementation, dann aber die nach außen hin zu abstrahieren durch objektorientierte Software-Strukturen und zusammen skripten, tut man das in Python. Das heißt, da instanziert man sich dann hier so einen AMD-Modulator und irgendwie einen Verstärker und was weiß ich, einen Filter. Und da sagt man einfach, ich will jetzt einen neuen Filter haben mit diesen Parametern Punkt und dann kriegt man den halt. Dann verbindet man Input und Output jeweils mit einer Zeile in Python und dann hat man seinen Empfänger zusammen.
Das heißt, man malt sich sozusagen mit Python-Code seine eigene Leiterbahn zusammen und steckt da die Steinchen rein. So wie man sozusagen die Hardware designen würde, macht man das Ganze dann in Software.
Richtig. Und das ist natürlich schon so, dass diese Python-Software, also dass es da fertige Python-Programme gibt für bestimmte Anwendungsfälle. Ich meine, die einfachen Beispiele, die mitgeliefert sind, sind eben zum Beispiel ein AM und FM-Radio-Empfänger. Den kann ich auf der Kommandezeile starten und ich sage irgendwelche Frequenzen, die ich hören will. Dann kann ich die von Fritz eingeben oder so und dann kriege ich halt auf dem Lautsprecher irgendwie Radio Fritz.
Wo kriegt ihr die jetzt her?
Das ist eben die Frage dessen, was für eine Hardware man hat, um den Empfang zu bewerkstelligen. Und da wird von Radio eine ganze Menge unterschiedlicher Hardware unterstützt. Vieles davon ist relativ teuer, weil es aus dem professionellen Elektronikbereich kommt. Die einfachste Variante, mit der man aber leider nicht sehr weit kommt, ist die eigene Soundkarte zu verwenden. Die hat ja auch einen Analog-Digital-Wandler, leider einen relativ beschränkten, in der Regel 48 Kilo Samples oder so was derartiges. Je nachdem, was man sich anschauen möchte, kann das auch schon interessant sein. Es gibt zum Beispiel dieses DRM, nicht im Sinne von Digital Restrictions Management, sondern dieses neue Digitale Kurzwellen-Funk. Da kann man sich jetzt einen uralten, billig Kurzwellen-Empfänger ohne Digital-Integration nehmen. Man kann an die Kopfhörer-Buchse seine Soundkarte anschließen. Da kommt dann das digitale Signal raus. Das klingt halt irgendwie doof, wie ein Modem am Telefon. Ja, so etwas in die Richtung. Das geht eben in die Soundkarte rein. Auf der anderen Seite habe ich dann nur Radio. Da kann ich dann Software laufen lassen.
Wie der Chaosradio-Jingle. So klingt das.
Genau, richtig. Da kommt das ja ursprünglich her. Die Modems haben sich dann nur abgekupfert.
Genau, das war die Vorlage für die gesamte Entwicklung.
Also ich habe kein Patent drauf. Also das ist sozusagen die Vorgehensweise.
Also das reicht. Ich nehme einfach einen Kurzwellenempfänger. Ich stelle ihn auf die Frequenz ein. Senden schon viele einen DRM?
Doch, ja.
Ich habe das auch nicht so verfolgt. Ich weiß nicht, ob es das gibt. Deswegen wusste ich jetzt auch gleich den Begriff.
Es ist halt, wie es in Europa aussieht, aber in Afrika glaube ich zum Beispiel sehr weit verbreitet.
Langmittel- und Kurzwelle. Es gibt auch DRM plus.
Das ist nur jetzt eines der möglichen Beispiele.
Ich finde das aber ein tolles Beispiel, weil das ist ja nun wirklich auch etwas, was einen sozusagen mit der Welt zusammenbringt. Dann hat man auch wieder dieses gute alte Funk-Feeling. Früher, wenn man sich mit Amateurfunkern unterhält, die schon vor 70 Jahren dabei waren, die erzählen einem noch mit glühenden Augen, wie sie dann so Signalempfangsbestätigungen bekommen haben von der anderen Seite der Welt. Ich glaube, wenn man jetzt so einen Kurzwellenempfänger an seinen Rechner hängt und mit eigener Software sich sozusagen die Daten rausmumpelt, dann hat man zumindest so ein bisschen von diesem Gefühl wieder. Das ist heutzutage sehr schwierig mit dieser globalen Gemeinschaft, die immer so unglaublich nah ist, sowas auch noch irgendwie nachzuvollziehen.
Es gibt auch andere Beispiele, die ich mir jetzt vorstellen kann. Da ist meines Wissens nach keine Software fertig dafür innerhalb GNU Radio, aber das müsste man sich selber zusammenklicken. Es ist ja so, dass jede FM-Radio-Sendung inzwischen hat ADS drin. Ah ja, stimmt.
Radio-Datensystem.
Toller Begriff. Richtig, richtig. Eigentlich müsste man das ja auch mit GNU Radio dekodieren können. Das ist das digitale Signal.
Sollte man. Das heißt, man hat ein normales... Ja, ist ja nicht im hörbaren Bereich.
Ich überleg grad, das ist auf dem Filoton, der wieviel Kilohertz hat. Ja gut, es kann sein, dass es rausgefiltert wird. Weiß aber nicht, ob... Kann ich jetzt nicht sagen, ob es funktionieren würde.
Aber nicht deszots So ist das dann auch so für In-Band, digital geflöte...
Man könnte sicherlich auch... Man könnte sich alle möglichen Beispiele sammeln sammeln. Was ich jetzt noch sagen wollte, damit wir weiterkommen mit der Hardware. Es gibt einige Leute, die haben noch so sogenannte BT-848-Karten, falls sich da jemand dran erinnert. Also na, das ist der Prooggy 848-Chip-Satz. Das sind so Videograver-Karten.
Das sind diese Hauptauge-TV-Karten.
Ja, die gibt es auch... Gab es auch für viel billiger noch am Schluss irgendwie, für irgendwie 4 Euro oder so. Und die haben einen Analog-Digital-Wander, der bis auf, wenn ich es noch wisse, ich glaube 900 oder 600 Kilohertz oder was hochgeht. Also deren Audio-Eingang kann man irgendwie den Analog-Digital-Wander so hochfahren. Also einfach nur ohne Hardware-Veränderung. Das heißt, das ist einfach nur die Software. Und das wird auch unterstützt. Das heißt, wenn man jetzt, wenn man jetzt Signale mit höherer Frequenz digitalisieren will, das ist immer noch nicht sonderlich hoch, aber immerhin sehr billig. Und man kommt schon mal deutlich weiter als nur mit der Soundkarte. Und wenn man dann einen Schritt weitergehen möchte, dann gibt es, wie gesagt, professionelle Analog-Digital-Wandler-Karten, die eher so im 1000-Euro-Bereich oder im 1000-Der-Euro-Bereich sind. Das ist natürlich jetzt nicht jedermanns Sache. Aber eben, es gibt das Schwesterprojekt oder Zwillingsprojekt, kann man schon fast sagen, zu GNU Radio auf der Hardware-Seite und das ist das sogenannte USLP, Universal Software Radio Peripheral. Und das ist eben ein Gesät, was ein offenes Hardware-Design ist, für diesen generischen, also selbst im puristen Sinne, Radioempfänger. Das heißt, das ist ein Gerät, das besteht aus einem Mainboard und dann kann man Aufsteckplatinen drauf machen und das wird über USB mit dem PC verbunden und unter dem Radio kann man dann die Daten empfangen. Und da sind sehr schnelle Analog-Digital-Wandler und auch Digital-Analog-Wandler für die Sendeseite mit drauf. Und damit kann man dann schon richtig loslegen und beliebige Frequenzen empfangen. Der Analog-Digital-Wandler hat aber auch nur einen beschränkten Bereich. Ich weiß jetzt gerade nicht, ich glaube 128 Megasamples macht er in dem USRP. Das heißt, bis zu 64 Megahertz kann man direkt empfangen. FM Radio geht da noch nicht direkt damit. Da braucht man dann so eine Aufsteckplatine, die nennt sich Front-Ends. Und da wird diese Umsetzung gemacht, diese erste Mischstufe. Und da gibt es eben Front-Ends für meines Wissens nach alles bis 5,7 GHz oder so. Also die Front-Ends decken immer nur einen bestimmten Bereich ab. Das ist das, was ich gesagt hatte.
Das ist diese erste Aufspaltung.
Genau. Was kostet das? Das USRP, das Mainboard, kostet meines Wissens nach 900 US-Dollar.
Okay, da ist man auch im gleichen Bereich wie jetzt mit den anderen.
Nicht ganz. Ich brauche von 1.000 Dennen Euro.
1.000 Dennen Euro, okay.
Und Dollar ist ja auch nochmal ein deutlicher Unterschied inzwischen. Also 900 Dollar ist wahrscheinlich irgendwie 700 Euro oder so.
Kauft, solange der Euro stark ist.
Ja, ist es natürlich eine Investition, ist ganz klar. Das heißt, das wird sich jetzt nicht jeder irgendwie aus Spaß an der Freude einfach irgendwie kaufen. Aber es ist doch ein Preis, wo es genügend Enthusiasten gibt, die das mal dafür auf den Tisch legen. Ich meine, immerhin kann man dann richtig viel damit empfangen.
Aber ich wundere mich gerade, dass es jetzt eigentlich überhaupt nichts dazwischen gibt. Ich meine, wenn es schon diese BT848-Karte jetzt so einen AD-Wander hatte, der jetzt so einen großen Umfang hatte, gibt es nicht einfach auch noch so Karten, wo einfach jetzt nichts anderes drauf ist, als so einen AD-Wander mit einem großen Umfang?
Naja, der große Umfang ist in Anführungszeichen zu setzen. Also bei den BT848-Karten ist der Analog-Digital-Wander im großen Umfang, ein großer Umfang für Audio-Frequenzen. Ich sprach von 900 Kilohertz. Beim USRP sprachen wir schon von 128 Megasamples. Das ist nochmal ein Faktor von 150 oder irgendwas dazwischen in dem Fall. Das kostet einfach ein bisschen. Diese Analog-Digital-Wander sind einfach nicht ganz günstig. Und dann kommt dazu, dass das ja auch nicht in großen Stückzahlen gefertigt wird. Das heißt, das sind kleine Serien. Ich glaube, da wurden insgesamt, ich habe neulich wieder eines für einen CCC bestellt. Ich weiß die Seriennummer jetzt nicht im Kopf, aber ich würde sagen, da sind irgendwie 2000 Stück davon oder so, wenn überhaupt bisher produziert und verkauft worden. Das heißt, die Fertigung ist relativ teuer, da hat man ja sehr viel Einmalkosten und so. Ist also ein Kleinserienprojekt, oder ja, für normales Radio-Equipment.
Ja, ist kein iPod.
Richtig. Und das heißt, selbst wenn man das jetzt mit einem schlechteren Analog-Digital-Wand da machen will, dann wäre es vielleicht irgendwie 10, 20, 30 Dollar günstiger. Aber die ganzen Fixkosten dieser Kleinserie sind einfach irgendwie da. Verstehe. Und die Frontends zum draufstecken, die bewegen sich dann irgendwo zwischen, ich glaube, 40 und 200 Dollar oder so, je nachdem, was man jetzt für einen Frequenzbereich empfangen möchte.
Okay, das heißt, angenommen, ich würde mir jetzt so einen USRP kaufen, dann kann ich dann irgendwie, sagen wir mal, ich will jetzt auf einen Frequenzbereich hinaus. Dann haben wir nochmal, auf das Thema müssen wir jetzt sowieso eigentlich noch kommen. Ich würde jetzt mal wirklich ganz gerne mal ein bisschen beim GSM mit lauschen wollen. Also die vorhin schon genannten Frequenzbereiche von 850 MHz bis 1900 MHz. Dafür bräuchte ich dann die entsprechende Frontendkarte.
Das ist richtig. Wenn es rein um die Empfangsseite gibt, gibt es da ein Frontend, das nennt sich DBS-LX für Digital Broadcast Satellite Receive.
Das deckt dann welchen Frequenzbereich ab?
Ziemlich genau den von dir beschriebenen. Also ich glaube von 800 bis 2,3 oder so. Das ist einfach, was man da gemacht hat, ist, dass man einfach einen Satelliten-Tuner, also wie man ihn für Satellitenfernsehen benutzt, verwendet. Weil da ist es eben auch so, dass das Signal zwischen der Schüssel und deinem Satellitenempfänger ist auch zwischen so 900 und 2 Gigahertz. Also 900 Megahertz, 2 Gigahertz. Also in etwa dieses Spektrum. Und da nimmt man einfach so eine Standard-Komponente, die ist sehr billig, dieses Satelliten-Tuner, macht das eben auf eine kleine Platine, sodass sie auf diese sogenannten Daughter-Board-Sockets, also auf diese Schnittstelle, hardware-seitig, auf den USRP passt. Und dann kannst du da eine Antenne anbieten.
Und dann kannst du dieses Frontend nochmal dazu.
Das kann ich jetzt nicht auswendig sagen, ich bin auch nicht der versiegtes Mensch, aber 70 Dollar würde ich sagen.
Okay, also das ist jetzt nochmal ein nicht ganz so erheblicher Betrag, der dazu kommt. Darauf wollte ich eigentlich jetzt nur hinaus, nicht dass es nochmal dasselbe ist. Gut, das heißt, dann habe ich so ein Gerät, dem ich sagen kann, hier, lausch doch mal diesen und jeden Frequenzbereich rein. Und in dem Fall, also das Frontend sagt sozusagen, ich höre jetzt alles ab von 900, also es liefert sozusagen alles. Oder kann ich dann dem Gerät auch sagen, dass es sich von vornherein einschränken soll? Das ist dann aber schon ein Software sozusagen, oder wie?
Ja, na, es ist so, dass dieses Frontend eben, also in diesem spezifischen Fall, nehmen wir jetzt eben einfach den an, kann das Frontend dir eine bestimmte Bandbreite, also einen bestimmten Kanal, würde man sagen, heraus schneiden aus dem Spektrum.
Das macht es auch schon digital?
Das macht das in Hardware. Das ist nicht digital, der Schnitt. Das heißt also, du hast angenommen, du willst jetzt, sagen wir, 920 MHz oder irgendwas empfangen. Und dann kann dir dieses DBS Alex, kann dir sowas wie 910 bis 930 MHz heraus schneiden, das sind also 20 MHz insgesamt, und kann dir die herunterschieben, herunter mischen im Frequenzspektrum auf eben 0 bis 20 MHz. Das heißt, man greift sich das einfach weit oben im Spektrum raus und subtrahiert, in Anführungszeichen, also das Mischen, mathematisch ist es eine Multiplikation für die Leute, die sich damit beschäftigen wollen, mischt das hinunter und dann ist es eben 0 bis 20 MHz und damit ein Signal, was dieser 128 Megasample analog-digital-wandel locker samplen kann. Und da drin dann, also wenn du GSM dir anschaust, GSM hat, ich hatte es gerade offen, ich glaube, so etwas wie 200 Kilohertz Kanalbandbreite, 230 Kilohertz, irgend sowas. Das heißt, wenn du einen bestimmten Kanal im GSM-Bereich dir anhören möchtest, dann reicht es dir eigentlich, wenn du dir ein 230 Kilohertz-Scheibchen rausschneidest und nicht diese 20 MHz.
Aber wenn jetzt diese Filter- und Rausschneidegeschichte –also wir reden von analoge Hardware –wie kann denn dieser Hardware so flexibel sein, dass der sagen kann, jetzt bitte mal nur von da bis da? Habe ich das dann auch alles multiple für jede beliebige Wandbreite?
Nein, die Hardware ist erstmal ausgelegt für diesen, sage ich, 900 bis 2 GHz, das ist 900 MHz, 0,9 bis 2 GHz-Bereich. Und das ist das, was starr ist in der Hardware. Und innerhalb dessen, das Herausschneiden dieses Bandes, das ist das eigentliche Tuning, also auch im Sinne des Wortes. Früher analoges Radio mit Drehknopf zum Tunen. Und da wird auch tatsächlich eben, ursprünglich wurde ein Empfangsschwingkreis abgestimmt. Du hast einen Kondensator, der hat veränderbare Kapazität. Und dadurch tunest du diesen Schaltkreis, du stimmst ihn ab, auf die Frequenz, die du empfangen möchtest.
Hence the name Tuner.
Genau. Und das ist genau das Gleiche, was da passiert, nur dass der Drehknopf durch digitale Signale bedient wird.
Okay, also das läuft dann schon in Software. Ist das dann auch GNU Radio Software, die auf diesem Board läuft?
Auf dem Board läuft auch Software in der Tat. Und die Software kommt auch aus dem GNU Radio Projekt mit. Aber die eigentliche Signalverarbeitende Software, also das Signal Processing, die Demodulation, was man auch immer später macht mit dem Signal, das passiert auf dem PC. Auf dem Board ist so ein kleiner Prozessor, ein Mikrocontroller und ein FPGA, der zum Multiplexen unterschiedlicher Signale da ist. Aber da wird quasi keine Signalverarbeitung gemacht. Das ist nur so Steuerinformation. So was wie, da sind auch vier solche Sockel drauf. Das heißt, ich will jetzt mit diesem Sockel benutzen. Und ich will dann jetzt auf diese Frequenz tunen. Auch so was wie Identifikation wird da gemacht, damit das Board erkennen kann, welches Starterboard ist jetzt aufgesteckt.
Und was ist denn jetzt das Software, was da jetzt real stattfindet zu diesem Kondensator, den ich normalerweise mit dem Knopf drehe? Also welche Einheit tun da jetzt genau was?
Also gut, du hast eine Software auf dem PC. Die ist in Python geschrieben. Entweder eine fertige oder was du selber geschrieben hast. So, und da steht eine Anweisung drin, wie zum Beispiel, ich möchte ein 20 MHz-Scheibchen von 910 bis 930 MHz haben. Und das wird dann über den USRP-Driver, das ist ja eine Driver-Software auf dem PC, wird das an das USRP-Mainboard geschickt und dort dann über den sogenannten I2C-Bus an diesen Satelliten-Tuner weitergereicht. Da wird einfach nur gesagt, Satelliten-Tuner, jetzt hier 910 MHz und Bandbreite 20 MHz. Das ist also digital, da wird nur von der Software, von irgendeiner API, wird das in irgendwie Bits gefummelt und die Bits gehen als Kommandos über ein bestimmtes Protokoll an diesen Tuner hin. Und der Tuner selbst, der hat auch einen kleinen Mikrocontroller drin oder ein Digital-Schaltkreis. Der dreht dann sein virtuelles Rädchen.
Was aber auch nur Elektronik ist an der Stelle.
Das ist nur Elektronik, aber gemischt analog-digital. Das ist noch nichts, was im Sinne von Software-Defined Radio passiert.
Wir reden dann von integrierten Schaltkreisen, die so eine analoge Komponente haben und wo dann getunt werden kann. Man schreibt das von außen, verstehe. Alles klar. Das heißt, USRP selber ist überhaupt kein Prozessing-Teil, sondern organisiert, dass man da dieses Frontend-Teil drauf machen kann. Was ist denn dann auf dem USRP selbst noch übrig, wenn das schon das Teure ist?
Die analog-digital-Wanderung und digital-analog in der hohen Geschwindigkeit.
Das heißt, das Frontend-Board liefert ein analoges Signal und die Digitalisierung. Das ist das, was das USRP macht.
Das ist richtig, ja. Und dann ist auf dem USRP noch ein Baustein, der die USB-Kommunikation handelt, weil es über USB 2 verbunden ist mit dem Rechner. Und es ist noch ein FPGA drauf, ein Programmierbarer Logik-Baustein, wo viele Leute denken, oh, Software for a Radio mit FPGA. Nein, aber die eigentliche Bearbeitung des Signals wird nicht in diesem FPGA gemacht. Der ist hauptsächlich dazu da, weil es, wie gesagt, zwei analoge Eingangs-, also zwei analog-digital-Wanderer und zwei digital-analog-Wanderer sind. Das heißt, man spricht da mit sehr vielen unterschiedlichen Komponenten. Dann diese Steuersignale dazu und so. Und dieser FPGA ist im Wesentlichen dazu da, diese ganzen Signale zu multiplexen und sie über USB zu schicken bzw. von USB zu empfangen. Und man kann in dem schon ganz, ganz, ganz simple Verarbeitungsstritte machen. Aber da wird nur so was gemacht wie Dezimierung von Samplenaten und so was. Also, dass man einfach von einer hohen Sample-Rate, die aus dem analog-digitalen Lager kommt, dass man jedes zweite Sample wegwirft oder so was in die Richtung und das dann weiterreicht dann zu USB. Also keinerlei hochmathematischen...
Okay, ich denke, die Trennung ist jetzt relativ klar geworden. Frontend reduziert es sozusagen auf das in Frage kommende Band, liefert was Analoges, das wird auf dem USRP digitalisiert und mit Hilfe der Software auf dem FPGA schnell per USB in den Rechner geschoben. Und dort sitzt jetzt ein gieriges Stück Software, was sich diesem Datenstrom einverleibt, der aber nichts anderes ist als eine digitale Repräsentierung der Funkwelle des in Frage kommenden Bereichs. Ab jetzt geht es eigentlich erst los. Jetzt muss man sozusagen aus diesem Datengewitter seine Blitze extrahieren. Richtig. Nicht ohne Grund habe ich jetzt mal diesen GSM-Frequenzbereich herausgepickt. Es gab ja hier bei Chaosradio Express schon eine Ausgabe Nr. 56, wo der GSM selbst intensiv diskutiert. Und zwar eben genau vor dem Hintergrund, dass eben Software entsteht, die GSM lesen und vielleicht in Zukunft auch irgendwann mal schreiben soll, das sogenannte GSM Software Project hat sozusagen vor, auf Basis von reiner Software das GSM-Protokoll zu implementieren. Heutzutage hat man eben so einen GSM-Stein in seinem Handy drin und die sind auch alle irgendwie hochamtlich abgenommen und natürlich sauber lizensiert. Und entsprechend damit sind sozusagen bug-kompatibel zu den GSM-Netzen. Und das GSM-Projekt möchte jetzt gerne Hardware schaffen, mit der man das eben auch machen kann, aber die eben frei programmierbar ist. Software schaffen, aber letzten Endes entsteht ja da auch etwas Hardware. Aber gut, vielleicht können wir ja mal, kannst du nochmal so mit deinen Worten das GSM-Software-Projekt zusammenfassen. Wer es halt ausführlicher haben will und wer auch in GSM selber nochmal einen Einblick haben will, dem empfehle ich halt Chaosradio Express 56 ohnehin eine unserer meistgefragten Sendungen hier. Vor allem, weil ja der letzte Stand der war, dass eben große Tabellen gerade berechnet wurden, um diese ganze Dekodierung und so weiter vorzunehmen und sozusagen auch den eigentlichen A5-Algorithmus, der alles verschlüsselt, zu knacken. Du hast dich ja ein bisschen auch mit dem Projekt beschäftigt. Was ist denn da der Stand der Dinger?
Ja, also generell ist es so, dass dieses GSM-Projekt von THC, also Hackers Crew, eine Hacker-Gruppe initiiert wurde. Und das ist einfach erstmal ein Sammelbecken von allen möglichen Leuten, die schon immer gerne mal mit GSM spielen wollten, gewesen. Und dann hat sich im Laufe der Zeit herausstrukturiert, einzelne Arbeitsgruppen, einzelne, die einen bestimmten Fokus auf bestimmten Teilaufgaben haben und dann jeweils teilweise auch noch unterschiedliche Teams parallel mit unterschiedlichen Ansätzen. Und ein Teil sicherlich ist das sogenannte A5 Cracking Project. Da geht es also darum, den sogenannten A5-Algorithmus innerhalb des GSMs und proprietärer Verschlüsselungsalgorithmus zu knacken. Das ist aber erstmal ein für sich genommen autarkes Projekt, das nur diesen Fokus hat und das also hier auch sehr weit fortgeschritten ist. Ich kann jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht sagen, was der letzte Stand der Dinge war diesbezüglich. Und dann gibt es eben aber auch andere Projekte, die sich mit der Empfangsseite des Protokolls beschäftigen. Das ist ja auch getrennt davon. Ich kann ja erstmal empfangen, auch wenn ich einen bestimmten Teil davon noch nicht entschlüsseln kann, aber zumindest das ganze Protokoll aufdröseln und den eigentlichen Empfangstimulationsprozess usw.
Das ganze Callhandling ist ja auch unverschlüsselt. Das ist ja eigentlich nur der Telefonanruf selber, der verschlüsselt ist, aber die GSM-Kommunikation läuft da offen ab und die kann man ja einfach lauschen.
Genau. Und für diese Empfangsgeschichte, da gibt es eigentlich drei unterschiedliche Ansätze, die verfolgt wurden innerhalb dieses Projekts. Einer davon eben mit Hilfe des USRP und des GNU Radius, der ist auch inzwischen, muss man sagen, am weitesten gedient. Am Anfang war das noch nicht so klar abzusehen. Ist auch mein persönlicher Favorit natürlich, weil diese, wer sich für Funk interessiert, für GSM und so weiter dieses USRP, ja, das ist mal eine Investition, aber damit kann man noch viel mehr schöne Dinge treiben. Wir haben im CCC auch gerade eine Arbeitsgruppe, die das gleiche mit DECT tut zum Beispiel, also dem Digital European Cordless Telefoniestandard. Das will man auch einfach mal empfangen können und so weiter. Aber das nur am Rande erwähnt, ein anderer Ansatz, der dort verfolgt wurde zu dem USRP, kommen wir gleich zurück, ist mit einem speziellen Telefon, einem sogenannten TSM30, was ein Telefon, glaube ich, einer französischen Firma war, ist längst nicht mehr aktiv im Verkauf, man kriegt die noch auf Ebay. Und das ist ein GSM-Telefon, wo es ein Software Development Kit vom Hersteller gibt, da kann man also Anwendungen schreiben, die auf dem Telefon selber laufen. Und ich spreche jetzt hier nicht von einem Smartphone, wo man unter Windows Mobile oder Linux oder einem anderen Betriebssystem eine Anwendung schreibt, sondern das ist tatsächlich Code, der auf dem Prozessor mit dem GSM-Stack selbst läuft. Und da hat man natürlich auch eine relativ nahe Möglichkeit, an das GSM-Photokoror ranzukommen. Die Leute haben aber mit allen möglichen Schwierigkeiten gekämpft und sind meines Wissens nach nicht sonderlich weit gekommen bisher, wird aber nach wie vor versucht. Der Hintergrund ist einfach, naja, es ist ein handliches Gerät, das kann man irgendwie leicht mal ans Laptop anschließen und das ist auch nicht auffällig, wenn man ein Telefon am Laptop anschließt und damit durch die Gegend läuft. Wohingegen, wenn ich jetzt mein USRP auspacke, die Platine mit... und dann noch irgendwie eine Antenne da dran und so weiter. Das ist auch der Stromverbrauch natürlich.
Da muss man sich ordentlich ausreden. Ich bin hier der lokale Ghostbuster.
Du machst Messungen zur elektromagnetischen Verträglichkeit. Die Arbeitsplätze werden irgendwie verstütten.
Ich bin irgendwie... Nach Tschernobyl hatte ich viel Spaß da, wenn ich in einem Besen stieh, durch die Gegend zu laufen, einfach nur kritzelne Geräusche voll mitzugeben. Das hat die Leute schon sehr unruhig gemacht.
Das am Rande wird noch weiterverfolgt. Ich halte es auch für einen interessanten Ansatz und einen anderen Ansatz, der natürlich sehr oberflächlich im Vergleich zu den anderen ist, war, ein sogenanntes Trace Mobile zu verwenden. Es gibt ja spezielle Telefone, die von Operatoren selber und von Servicepersonal benutzt werden, dass es einem mehr Informationen gibt über das, was da abläuft. Also quasi ein GSM-Telefon nicht für den End-User, sondern für jemanden, der Netz wartet. Das hat unter Umständen auch eine sehr schöne Schnittstelle, wo irgendwie Packet-Dumps und sowas rauskommen. Genau, die sind natürlich relativ teuer. Das ist natürlich schwer zu bekommen. Meistens relativ teuer und so weiter. Und hat damit nicht so ganz den gleichen Fokus in die Zielrichtung wie die anderen Ansätze. So, und das mit dem GNU Radio. Selbst mit diesem Ansatz, GNU Radio plus USRP, gab es unterschiedliche Leute, die sich den Problemen gewidmet haben, mit unterschiedlichen Strategien. Es gibt da im Wesentlichen zwei Software-Pakete im Moment dafür, innerhalb dieses Projekts. Und beide übernehmen also die Aufgabe, erstens mal die Demodulation der Daten, das Modulationsverfahren, das eingesetzt wird bei GSM heißt, ist das jetzt kein Buchstabendreher, GMSK, was für Gaussian Minimum Shift Keying steht. Also das Modulation oder wird oft als Keying bezeichnet, wenn es um digitale Modulation geht, und da gibt es halt einen Analog zum Beispiel, es gibt die Phasenmodulation PM oder die Amplitudenmodulation AM, und wenn man das digital macht, dann spricht man immer von Keying, also aus AM wird ASK, aus PM wird PSK, aus FM wird FSK, und dann gibt es so einen Spezialmodus, wo man das Signal noch auf geringere Bandbreite trimmt, und das nennt sich dann Gaussian Minimum Shift Keying. Das ist so ein Zwischending einer abgemodelten Phasenmodulation. Und das ist sozusagen erstmal der erste Schritt. Also ich muss erstmal eine Frequenz finden oder einstellen, dann muss ich demodulieren, und danach bekomme ich irgendwie einen demodulierten Datenstrom, und der muss dann noch dekodiert werden. Ja, dekodiert meine ich jetzt nicht im Sinne von Verschlüsselung, sondern die Daten sind ja strukturiert. Da gibt es bestimmte Pakete, die haben Anfang, die haben Ende, da gibt es Füller-Bits, und dann sind das eine Vielzahl logischer Kanäle bei GSM, die in Zeitschlitze hinein multiplexed werden in ganz komplizierten Strukturen. Also GSM ist wirklich auf dieser Ebene, auf der Ebene des Encodings ein hochkomplexes Protokoll.
Das ist sozusagen die allererste Schicht, da wohl die Bits überhaupt erst mal in die Frequenz geballert werden. Das muss man erst mal auspacken, und dann geht es erst an irgendeine logische Interpretation.
Genau, aber auch eben die logische Interpretation dieser Bits ist, was ich meinte mit den logischen Kanälen. Also wenn man dann den Bitdatasturm hat, dann auch diese Bits auseinander zu fummeln, das ist also echt nicht ohne, weil man muss sich eben bei GSM noch mal kurz als Abriss vorstellen. Man hat eben eine Frequenz und diese Frequenz, also eine Trägerfrequenz, dann bleibt man bei diesen 920 MHz, das passt so schön rein. Und da ist eben ein Band von 230 Kilohertz, darin ist sozusagen ein physischer Kanal. Und der wird unterteilt in Zeitschlitze, das ist ja ein sogenanntes TDMA-Verfahren, Time Division Multiple Access, das heißt, es gibt Zeitschlitze, wenn ich mich recht entsinne, bei GSM 900 sind das acht Zeitschlitze auf jedem Kanal. Und, nein, jetzt habe ich schon das falsche Wort, auf jeder Frequenz, acht Zeitschlitze. Und das ist dann eben der physische Kanal, ist ein Zeitschlitz innerhalb einer Frequenz. Und dann innerhalb dieses Zeitschlitzes wird dann ein Bit-Multiplex gemacht, wo quasi jedes Bit da drin, fast aus einem anderen logischen Kanal stammt. Genau. Und die dann unter Umständen wieder noch aus anderen, feineren Kanälen bestehen. Also dieser Bit-Multiplex, der ist echt...
Warum wird das so auffällig gemacht? Ist das für Sicherungen?
Nein, das ist einfach so, dass man, dass man ein Protokoll halt möglichst sinnvoll strukturiert, sinnvoll im Sinne dessen, was man auch in Hardware umsetzen kann. Also vor allem, als die Geräte ja noch neu waren, die ganze Technologie. Und es gibt natürlich sowas wie Sprachdaten. Da ist jedem klar, gut, das ist ein Kanal, und der hat einen Zeitschlitz, und da werden eben die Samples reingepackt. Und dann gibt es aber sehr viele andere Kanäle noch für Kontrolldaten zum Beispiel, also dieses Verbindungsaufbau, Verbindungsabbau, Signalisierung von, oh, der andere hat aufgelegt, so diese Dinge. Das ist auch klar. Das ist erstmal ein Out-of-Band-Kanal, also nicht im Sprachkanal, wo Kontrollinformationen übertragen werden, auch zwischen zwei Punkten.
Aber es muss ja immer garantiert werden, dass die Sprache in Echtzeit verfügbar ist, und deswegen ist alles zeitgetaktet.
Das auch, ja. So, und dann kommt dazu, dass, das sind aber alles zwischen zwei Punkten stattfindende Kommunikationen. Und dann gibt es aber ja noch so Dinge, die das eigentliche sogenannte Mobility-Management ausmachen. Also sowas wie, dass die Zelle erstmal von sich aus sagt, hallo, ich bin eine Zelle, ich hab die und die ID, ich hab die folgenden Nachbarzellen, die sind auf diesen anderen Frequenzen, solche Dinge, das ist der sogenannte Broadcast Control Channel, der BCCH. Und das ist ein Point-or-Multi-Point. Also da sagt die Zelle erstmal, die broadcastet Informationen über sich. Ja, das empfängt jedes Telefon und kann dann sich optimierter oder überhaupt in das Netz einbuchen oder in andere Zellen versuchen zu empfangen und so weiter. Und dann gibt es aber auch so Dinge wie Cell-Broadcast zum Beispiel. Das ist ein Feature, was nur die wenigsten Leute kennen, die Mobiltelefone benutzen. Aber es ist so was wie eine SMS nur, dass sie eben für jedermann empfangbar ist. Dazu werden auch so Dinge wie die aktuelle Vorwahl der wandenden Homezone oder wie auch immer der Marketing-Terminus heute ist des jeweiligen Anbieters.
Sie sind in ihrer Homezone.
Ja, solche Dinge werden da auch so abgewickelt. Und es ist auch wieder ein Punkt-zu-Multi-Punkt-Kanal. Und dann gibt es sehr viel auch innerhalb des Protokolls selbst, also wo die Basisstation mit dem Telefon ausmacht, mit welcher Feldstärke jetzt gesendet wird. Weil wenn die ganz nah beieinander sind, dann wird man natürlich zum Verringern des Stromverbrauchs irgendwie die Sendeleistung verringern. Oder es gibt so Dinge wie das tatsächliche sogenannte Timing-Advance. Also wenn die Basisstation und Telefone weit auseinander sind, dann ist die Lichtgeschwindigkeit tatsächlich schon so langsam, dass man dem Telefon sagt, du musst jetzt aber so und so viele Mikrosekunden vor deinem eigentlichen Zeitschlitz senden, damit es dann im Zeitschlitz bei der Station ankommt.
Verdammt, die Lichtgeschwindigkeit ist einfach an die Anforderungen unserer modernen Kommunikation einfach nicht mehr gewachsen. Es wird Zeit für Lichtgeschwindigkeit 2.0.
Ja, unbedingt.
Auweia. Okay, gut, das sind also alles solche Anforderungen, die damit drinstecken. Deswegen ist dieses ganze physikalische Encoling der Bits so schwierig. Das macht natürlich den Aufwand auch für die Software entsprechend schwer. Wie weit ist man denn in diesem GSM-Projekt damit?
Das ist sehr gut, aber ich möchte noch eine Ergänzung, damit es noch klarer wird, warum man jetzt so viele verschiedene Kanäle hat. Es ist halt so, dass die Bitrate fix ist, die da zur Verfügung steht. Die Brutto-Bitrate. Die möchte man jetzt möglichst effizient aufteilen. Und so Dinge wie, hallo, ich bin die Zelle mit dir und der Nummer, die will man natürlich nur alle paar Sekunden oder so aussenden, nicht die ganze Zeit. Deswegen werden diese Kanäle so verschacht und aufgeteilt. Und dadurch gibt es dann einzelne Kanäle mit ganz krummen Bitsraten, so etwas wie 2,6 Kilobit pro Sekunde oder so.
Weil ich einfach nur ein paar Slots von diesen bekomme. Das heißt, man muss sich das so vorstellen wie so ein großes Wheel of Fortune, wo ganz viele kleine Markierungen an der Seite sind und irgendjemand dreht das Ding dann halt irgendwie durch. Du zeigst mir ja gerade irgendwie komplizierte Grafiken. Ich setze das jetzt mal in meinem Bild um. Ich habe vor mir dieses große Glücksrad, was irgendwie gedreht wird, aber immer mit derselben Geschwindigkeit. Und jedes Klack, Klack, Klack, Klack, Klack, was da da ist, ist sozusagen ein verfügbares Bild. Aber jedes Klack ist einem anderen Zweck zugewiesen. Und die meisten gehen natürlich für Sprache und Daten drauf und ein paar andere eben für Management und Sachen, die nicht so häufig vorkommen müssen und vor allem nicht so viele Daten übertragen werden und vor allem nicht permanent. Richtig. Und wie weit ist jetzt die Software? Die kann das alles schon dekodieren. Also dieses Ganze auseinanderklümpieren, das geht. Es wäre auch sozusagen schon die nächsthöhere Stufe der Interpretation dieses ganzen Managements. Also hier kommt ein Call für E-Mail sowieso, Telefon, tra-la-la möchte gerne angerufen werden und so weiter. Das Ganze aushandeln, wo er dann letzten Endes, das haben wir in der GSM-Sendung alles sehr plastisch auch erklärt, wo es dann sozusagen dann auch Verweise auf neue Kanäle kommen, mit irgendwie, hier ist jetzt ein Telefongespräch, das kommt auf einen anderen Kanal, jetzt musst du mal die Frequenz wechseln. Ja, und wie fertig ist das jetzt schon? Also wenn ich mir jetzt meinen Rechner schnappe und ich bestelle mir so ein USRP und bommel das da dran über USB, mach mal einen ganzen Treibbandstart, läuft das eigentlich nur unter Linux?
Nein, das läuft unter Mac OS, unter Windows und unter Linux. Auf anderen Systemen weiß ich nicht. Ich hab mal was von Solaris gehört, aber ich weiß nicht, wie gut da jetzt letztendlich die Unterstützung ist. Es gibt im Übrigen lustigerweise gerade einen Port auf die Playstation 3. Ach. Mit dem Hintergrund, dass da ja diese...
Also wir reden jetzt von dem USRP, nicht nur von GNU Radio, von dem gesamten System.
Weil nämlich die Playstation 3 ja diese SPS hat, diese Synergistic Processing Elements, also diese... Das ist ja aufgemotzte Power PC, der nicht nur einen Power PC hat, sondern sechs oder irgendwie so Synergistic Processing Units.
Die Cell-Processors.
Genau, Cell-Processor daneben hat. Und die sind ja extrem gut für Signalverarbeitung zu gebrauchen. Und da ist dann die Idee, dass man halt diesen Low-Level-Code, der die eigentlichen Algorithmen ausführt, auf diese Synergistic Processing Units eben umsetzt. Und dadurch in der Playstation einen sehr schnell arbeitenden Software-Defined Radio Rechner hat, sozusagen.
Das heißt, man schaltet, macht das, die hat auch USB, und man kann das USRP direkt an die Playstation ranballern, und dann kommt irgendwie aus der Playstation auf einer höheren Ebene sozusagen schon vorgekautes Material raus.
Genau, das kann man auf Ethernet wieder...
Telefonieren Sie doch mit Ihrer Playstation 3.
Das Setup wird immer lustiger, dass du das für deine Messungen hinfährst.
Wow, Telefonen, Blu-ray, Laufwerk, das ist doch mal was.
Ja, stell dir vor, dass du das USRP, deine Playstation und dein Laptop und du kommst in dein Video an.
Ja, so komisch sind sie noch nie angeschaut worden.
Ich weiß nicht, ob du The Sarah Connor Chronicles Terminator, diese neue Serie irgendwie kennst oder verfolgst oder was?
Ach, das gibt es jetzt auch als Fernsehserie?
Es gibt jetzt eine neue Terminator Fernsehserie.
Mit Arnold Schwarzenegger?
Der Governator ist nicht dabei. Nein, aber da gibt es eben auch lustigerweise, ich hab das zufällig gesehen, aber da gibt es quasi, es ist ja dieses ganze Terminator-Szenario mit irgendwie, die Menschen müssen in die Vergangenheit reisen, um zu verhindern, dass die Maschinen intelligent werden. Und da ist eben auch sozusagen der erste intelligente Computer, es ist ein Schachcomputer, der aus lauter irgendwie Game-Konsolen zusammengebaut ist.
Noch nicht gewusst, wieder was gelernt. Podcasting macht klug.
Ja, das war jetzt die Schleichwerbung, ich kriege dafür dann einen entsprechenden Scheck von...
Von irgendjemand, aber bestimmt nicht von mir. Wobei, vielleicht taucht das ja auch. Da muss man nachher noch mal ein bisschen die Piratenbucht anwerfen, glaube ich.
So, gut, aber wie gesagt, diese Software, die kann man sich installieren, man braucht da auch keinen Linux dazu. Ich weiß nicht, ob speziell diese Python-Skripts aus dem GSM-Projekt, die man schon mal für GNU Radio unter Windows benutzt hat. Das weiß ich nicht. Aber generell, GNU Radio mit USRP läuft also auf unterschiedlichen Systemkonfigurationen. Wird auch aktiv von Leuten benutzt. So, dann kommen wir zurück zu dem, wo ist der Stand der Dinge mit dem GSM-Projekt. Ich muss sagen, es kann sein, als Disclaimer, es gab jetzt gerade in den letzten zwei Wochen eine neue Software-Release. Die habe ich mir noch nicht angeguckt, aber alles, was eben vorher da ist, ist mein Wissensstand. Da war es eben so, dass die Demodulation, das Herausfummeln der Bits und das Demultiplexen der Bits in diese einzelnen logischen Kanäle alles implementiert war. Und dann gibt es eben zwei, ich hatte ja anfangs schon erwähnt, es gab zwei unterschiedliche Ansätze. Der eine davon implementiert dann selbst noch so eine Art Protocol-Dumper. Also wo man dann irgendwie das in Menschen lesbare Information aufbereitet, so eine Art TCP-Dumpf für GSM. Und der andere Ansatz ist, das eher in einen PCAP-File zu schreiben, also das ist so ein Standard für Paket-Dumps im Netzwerkbereich, also im TCP-IP-Ethernet-Bereich. Und dann mit einem Wireshark Plugin, Wireshark ist ein Protokoll-Analysesoftware mit GUI und so weiter, da dann drauf loszulassen und drauf loszufahren. Und dann hat man wirklich das Schicki-GUI mit Suchfunktionen und so weiter und so weiter. Was also fehlt, das klingt jetzt ganz ganz toll, also es ist ja quasi schon komplett nach meiner Beschreibung, aber was fehlt, sind halt so die Details am Rande. Also der Prozess im Moment, wenn man da rangeht, oder eben mit der Software, die ich zuletzt hatte, war, naja, erstmal wirfst du Software an, die herausfindet, auf welchen Frequenzen ist überhaupt GSM los. Ja, damit du überhaupt mal siehst, aha, hier und da ist irgendwie ein GSM-Kanal. Und dann merkst du dir quasi, was da für eine Frequenz war, dann stoppst du das Programm und startest ein anderes Programm und sagst ihm jetzt, dekodier mal diese Frequenz. Und dann geht es eben los. Und auch so Dinge wie natürlich Frequenz-Jumps sind da noch nicht so implementiert. Ja, also gerade dieses, ah, jetzt bauen wir einen Sprachdatenkanal auf und springen mal auf eine andere Frequenz. Das bekommst du noch mit von der Basisstation, aber dann springt halt, du kannst jetzt nicht ein bestimmtes Gerät nachverfolgen oder so. Der Frequenzsprung wird dann nicht automatisiert gemacht und so.
Das wird derzeit nicht gemacht, aber das USRP kann ja relativ schnell umschalten, oder?
Das kann das. Es gibt da auch wieder unterschiedliche Ansätze, wie man das technische Detail löst. Einer davon ist, soweit ich weiß, implementiert. Ich weiß nicht, ob es schon veröffentlicht oder nicht. Ich verfolge das auf der Mailung des Themas so ein bisschen. Und das General Hopping und da gibt es einen anderen Ansatz, wo man das quasi, also einer davon ist wirklich, der Hardware zu sagen, sie soll die Frequenz wechseln, was mit einer gewissen Latenz verbunden ist, weil es muss ja über USB und so weiter und so weiter. Und die andere Variante ist einfach, wir samplen, genau, wir samplen einfach mal das ganze GSM-Band weg und wir fummeln das dann in Software hintereinander aus. Das ist halt so eher die Brute Force Methode.
Aber eigentlich nur eine Frage der notwendigen Prozessorkapazität oder der Komplexität, die das sozusagen für die Software ausführt.
Bei den Umständen auch geht es dann aber an die Grenzen dessen, was das USRP kann. Ich glaube, bei GSM 900 geht es noch. Das sind nicht ganz so viele Frequenzen. Ich glaube, so ungefähr 100 Kanäle, a 230 Kilohertz. Aber wenn es dann wirklich Richtung GSM 1800 oder 1900 geht, das sind es dann einfach zu viele. Das wäre zu breit, als dass man es noch irgendwie...
Das ist auch die Frage, ob das USB 2.0 dann irgendwie...
Das ist ein anderes Problem.
20 Megabyte erscheint mir jetzt nicht so viel.
Das ist richtig, das ist sehr richtig. Wobei, wie ich schon sagte, du kannst also in diesem FPGA auch schon wieder noch Dinge mit wegwerfen. Ja, die... Klar, ist alles frei und offen. Das wird auch gemacht unter Umständen. Und der andere Punkt ist, das hatte ich jetzt vorhin nicht erwähnt, es gibt also ein USRP 2, was sich in Entwicklung befindet. Und da wird es dann über Gigabit Ethernet gemacht. Das hat den angenehmen Vorteil, dass man es auch über längere Entfernungen besorgen kann.
Da steht das Ding da, wo man gut Frequenzempfang hat.
Genau, auf dem Dach mit der Antenne. Und hat dann Gigabit Ethernet am besten gleich noch über Optisch Potenziale.
Das ist aber in Entwicklung und auch nicht erhältlich.
Das ist in Entwicklung. Eigentlich hätte es schon erhältlich sein sollen, aber sie hatten da noch irgendwie Probleme und mussten es jetzt verschieben. Ich glaube, August, September ist so der angepeilte Zeitrahmen jetzt.
Okay, aber dann wäre sozusagen diese Bottleneck an der Stelle zumindest schon mal weg. Ist auch die Frage, was diese Frontends irgendwie...
Die kann man mitnehmen. Also der Sockel für die Frontends ist leicht, das heißt, die kann man weiterhin betreiben.
Und ist das Ding leistungsfähiger?
Ja, also deutlich schneller, was die Sample-Raten betrifft, damit man das Gigabit auch vollkriegt. Der FPGA, da hat sich unglaublich viel getan, was man irgendwie für bezahlbar das Geld bekommt. Das heißt, da ist ein richtig fetter FPGA mit drauf, in dem man dann auch mehr machen könnte, wenn man das denn wollte.
Aber eigentlich ist es sinnvoll, dass man wirklich jetzt den ganzen GSM-Bereich, also zumindest, sagen wir mal, dieses 1 in 900 MHz-Band oder sowas, sich schnappt. Und dann macht man eben die Aufteilung in die einzelnen Kanäle, macht man dann schon in GNU Radio in Software. Ist ja für den, also ist ja rein jetzt von der Aufgabenstellung her für GNU Radio kein Problem, sondern erfordert einfach nur Processing-Power.
Ja, und zwar verdammt viel.
Verdammt viel. Was ist verdammt viel? Also gibt es die Prozessoren schon, die jetzt das alles gleichzeitig bearbeiten können?
Alle GSM-Kanäle gleichzeitig wegsamplen, aber das glaube ich nicht, dass du irgendein Rechner-System bekommst, auf dem GNU Radio auch läuft, mit dem du das machen kannst. Also das ist einfach nur mal zu groß.
Ja, aber wie viele Faktoren müssen wir da noch abwarten?
Faktor 100 vielleicht, würde ich mal sagen. Oder vielleicht 50. Also irgendwas in dem Dreh. Also auf keinen Fall 1000, aber schon noch in einem erheblichen Faktor. Also es wird nicht jeden in zwei, drei Jahren schon gehen. Das liegt aber an ganz unterschiedlichen Dingen. Zum einen ist halt der Fokus von GNU Radio erstmal Flexibilität vor Hochoptimierung. Das heißt, da wird auch viel nicht unbedingt sehr effizient genutzt. Man versucht natürlich, das effizient wie möglich zu machen, aber der Fokus ist eben, wir wollen diese flexiblen Building Blocks, wir wollen ein Toolkit haben, mit dem man erstmal alles implementieren kann. Optimieren kann man das später immer noch.
Ja, vor allem ist ja auch eine Frage der Strategie. Wenn man jetzt wirklich mal vorhat, wir wollen heute Abend mal GSM mitschneiden, dann kann man das ja erstmal alles auf Platte schieben, und danach decodiert man ja eh nur das, was man braucht. Man hat zwar alle Kanäle aufgezeichnet, aber man weiß dann, wenn man es jetzt wirklich decodiert, da kommt dieser Anruf, auf den wir gewartet haben, der ist jetzt auf Band sowieso, da muss ja auch nur der auseinandergenommen werden. Von daher reicht ja dann die normale Processing-Power auch.
Das ist richtig und das ist durchaus eine sehr gangbare Strategie. Die Datenmengen sind natürlich auch unter Umständen wieder ein bisschen groß, aber auf jeden Fall hat man unterschiedliche Ansätze und eine Kombination dessen ist wahrscheinlich das, wo man zum Erfolg kommt. Also sowas wie vielleicht demodulieren, also dass die Bits schon rauskommen und dann die Bits mitschreiben oder so. Dann ist der Storage-Bedarf nicht so hoch, aber auch der Processing-Bedarf nicht so hoch. Also irgendwo so ein Kompromiss kann man da bestimmt finden. Aber wie gesagt, im Moment ist jetzt erst mal der Schritt, dass man überhaupt in real-time mitspringen kann, wenn man weiß, was man jetzt anhören will, dieses Hopping, die Software auch anwendbar zu machen. Auch sowas wie natürlich dann mal die Information auswerten. Also wie gesagt, so eine Zelle broadcastet der Information über die Nachbarzellen. Das will man natürlich in die Software zurückführen, damit die Software auch weiß, was sind da für andere Zellen und dann was weiß ich, was die Senderspeicher automatisch belegt. Das man sagt, ich will jetzt aber mal kurz zu Vodafone, jetzt vielleicht irgendwie zu D-Mobile und dann noch eine Anzebarstation usw. Also das dann auch aufzubereiten und interaktiver zu gestalten. Und vor allem dann auch die Informationsauswertung. Also wie präsentiere ich dann diese ganzen Daten dem Anwender gegenüber und so. Da gibt es noch viel zu tun, aber die wirklich harten Probleme der Signalverarbeitung, die sind gelöst alle. Das hat auch lange gedauert jetzt. Wie ich schon sagte, ich habe selber mich angefangen, ich glaube vor drei, vier Jahren habe ich mich damit beschäftigen. Also ich bin eigentlich ein aus der Analog-Funktechnik herauskommender Mensch und hatte mit diesem ganzen digitalen Signalverarbeitung nichts am Hut. Ich habe mich da eingelesen und ich finde immer, das ist angewandte Mathematik und nichts anderes. Man muss halt wirklich diese ganze Mathematik mitbringen, man muss diese ganzen Wellenteorie-Geschichten verstehen, man muss so ein bisschen Bezug zur Funkwelt haben, zur Physik, ja, und das ist schon ein sehr breites Anforderungsprofil an Leute, die dann da wirklich, so wie Eric Blossom oder andere, mal so eben das Zeug einfach drauf loscoden können. Das können nur wenige.
Aber um es anzuwenden, muss man jetzt nicht so viel draufhaben.
Genau, das ist das, was ich sage. Diese ganzen harten Probleme sind gelöst und jetzt haben wir halt sowas wie einen TCP-Dumpf. Analog wie in der Netzwerkwelt, man muss jetzt halt die Protokolle verstehen, muss GSM vielleicht noch ein bisschen verstehen können im Moment, muss sich da ein bisschen einlesen, aber das ist alles nichts, wo man sich mit der Signalverarbeitung, also die Probleme sind alle gelöst. Das ist jetzt alles Protokolldaten.
Ja, jetzt kommt der spaßige Teil. Wenn der A5-Algorithmus sich schnell knacken lässt, dann wird es natürlich richtig haarig, weil dann kann man natürlich ordentlich mithören, sowohl Telefonate als auch SMS dekodieren. Dann haben wir sicherlich bald das nächste Security-Problem. Da ist man auf absehbare Zeit bei GSM nicht mehr sicher. Ich denke, das kann man jetzt schon mal relativ klar voraussagen. Da ist die Zeit einfach am Ticken.
Auf der anderen Seite ist die Zeit auch bei GSM am Ticken, weil UMTS-Deployments weltweit auf dem Vormarsch sind.
Auf dem Vormarsch, aber ich habe mir gestern noch mal die Abdeckungskarten von Deutschland angeschaut. Vormarsch sieht anders aus. In den Ballungszentren hat man UMTS, aber die Abdeckung von GSM, bis GSM wirklich abgeschaltet wird, vergeht noch einiges.
Das ist richtig.
Wenn man Methoden findet, wie man UMTS-Telefone in den GSM-Fallback zwingen kann, dann ist sicherlich GSM noch eine Weile eine interessante Datenquelle.
Ja, gehe ich auch davon aus. Ich sage nur, es ist jetzt eigentlich sehr spät. Dafür, dass das System so lange in der realen Welt irgendwie getrieben wird, finde ich sehr spät, dass man jetzt sozusagen, wo der Nachfolger schon ein paar Jahre nach Markteinführung ist, dass man erst jetzt zu diesem Schritt kommt, das ist bedauerlich. Das ist aber auch etwas, wo ich vielleicht an der Stelle noch als Ausblick auch irgendwie erwähnen möchte. Warum beschäftige ich mich eigentlich so mit diesen ganzen Dingen? Also ich habe ja RFID-Projekte gemacht mit Friar Software, Opener Hardware. Gut, jetzt GNU Radio Entwicklungen habe ich mich selber nicht beteiligt, auch nicht bei der USRP oder bei diesem GSM, aber ich verfolge das zumindest ein Spiel damit. Der Punkt ist einfach der, also ich bin jemand, der kommt aus der traditionellen Netzwerksicherheit, also Ethernet, TCP-IP, Protokoll-Layer bis hoch eben zu Anwendungslayern und Security in dem Bereich. Und da gibt es ja ein unglaublich großes Forschungsgebiet und eine Industrie dahinter und es gibt ja nichts, wo irgendwie die Sicherheit so bis ins letzte Detail analysiert und realisiert wird und versucht wird, sie zu brechen wie im Internetbereich. Und das ist für mich aber eigentlich der Normalfall, weil ich sage mal, ich bin im Internet aufgewachsen und es sind so viele andere Protokolle um uns herum. Also die GSM ist eines davon, DECT, also diese digitalen Schnurrlohstelefone sind anderes, die RFID-Protokolle sind neuere, aber auch quasi ähnliche Protokolle.
Wo ja jetzt sozusagen gerade diese Systeme auch zusammenstürzen.
Ja, aber eben erst jetzt und das Problem, die Frage ist, warum ist das so? Und die einfache Antwort, die ich dafür geben kann, ist, weil es Ethernet-Karten gibt im Internetbereich. Da habe ich eine Karte, die stecke ich in meinen Rechner, da stecke ich ein Kabel dran und ich schalte die in Promiscuous Mode und ich bekomme für, also die Karte kann ich kaufen für keine Ahnung, wie billig die inzwischen sind, 5 Euro oder so. Und damit kann ich alles empfangen und lesen und dekodieren und kann mich damit beschäftigen.
Aber im Vorbereich ist es halt nicht so einfach.
Richtig, genau. Und das ist, finde ich, dringend notwendig, dass diese ganzen Protokolle und Standards und Verfahren auch nur annähernd ein bisschen dieser, wie soll ich sagen, diesen Augen, diesen mehr an Augen, die da drauf schauen, ausgesetzt wird.
Grundtestbedarf.
Richtig, weil das Zeug nämlich alles auseinanderfällt.
Oh ja, oh ja, das wird bestimmt ganz blutig werden. Vielleicht noch mal so ein paar Beispiele auch, was man so mit GNU Radio machen kann, fernab jetzt von GSM, was ja so ein bisschen der heilige Gral ist gerade. Also wir haben es schon erwähnt, deckt, und RFID-Systeme sind natürlich so die digitalen, die digitalen Kommunikationssysteme, die in weiter Benutzung sind bzw. immer weiter Verbreitung finden werden in der nächsten Zeit, was RFID betrifft. Was fällt dir sonst noch so ein, worauf man sich stürzen könnte und wofür GNU Radio dann auch... Also was kannst du noch empfehlen, was man mit GNU Radio Spannendes machen kann, was jetzt...
Komm du mal auf die Zielgruppe drauf an. Also was man als nicht signalverarbeitungsversierter Mensch machen kann, also wo es schon fertige Software dafür gibt sozusagen, du hattest eingangs ja erwähnt, dass John Gilmour mit einer der Sponsoren, oder wenn ich der Sponsor war, das vor allem meines Wissens nach des USRP-Projekts, das hat auch einen ganz bestimmten Hintergrund, und zwar gab es in den USA mal die sogenannte Broadcast Flag Debatte, wo ich weiß nicht wer wahrscheinlich die rechte Inhaberindustrie der Meinung war, naja, wir machen da jetzt ein Bit in unseren, also den Datenstrom, genau, für das digitale Fernsehen, und die Empfänger müssen halt einfach alle dieses Bit honorieren. Das heißt, wenn das Bit gesetzt ist, dann darf man diese Sendung hier aufzeichnen. Und damit hätte dann sozusagen die...
Kopierschutz per Akklamation sozusagen.
Genau, richtig. Das hat man ja schon mit Makrovision und Ähnlichem, bei DAT war das genau so. Ich erinnere mich richtig, solche Dinge.
Du darfst nichts aufzeichnen.
Ja, da gab es dann diese tollen Adapter, die man dazwischen steckt und dann ist das halt irgendwie verloren gegangen. Ja, es ist sogar noch differenzierter. Eine Kopie konnte man, glaube ich, machen und die zweite ist eine Kopie der Kopie in irgendeinem Schleiß.
Hat auf jeden Fall dazu geführt, dass DAT sich nicht wirklich durchgesetzt hat auf dem Markt und teure Profi-Hardware geblieben ist.
Ja, also das ist sozusagen der Hintergrund und GNU Radio und USRP hat damals, also das ist auch schon ein paar Jahre her, eben es geschafft, eine Software, also mit offener Hardware aus frei verfügbaren Hardware-Komponenten und ausschließlich freier Quellen offener Software einen RTSC, das ist der amerikanische digitalen Rundfunkstandard für Fernsehen, Empfänger zu bauen, wo man dieses Broadcast-Flag halt im Quellcode auskommentieren kann. Und ich weiß gar nicht, ob sie das überhaupt so reingeschrieben hatten. Ja, um zu demonstrieren so, ja, ihr könnt sozusagen nicht alle Empfänger regulieren, weil dann machen die Leute das halt in freier Software und dann, selbst wenn der originale Entwickler sich gesetzeskonform oder anfördungskonform verhält, jeder Anwender kann halt irgendwie Zeile 231 mal eine Rauthe in die erste Zeile machen, in die erste Zeiche machen und damit die Zeile auskommentieren oder so. Das heißt also, was ich damit sagen will, Empfang von zumindest dem amerikanischen Digitalfernsehstandard ist möglich. Nicht in realtime, zumindest damals nicht. Ich glaube, die Rechner sind inzwischen schnell genug, dass das gehen könnte. Es hat auch jemand implementiert, analogfernsehen, aber meines Wissens nach nur schwarz-weiß, weil die, also wer sich mit Fernsehsignalen auskennt, analogen, die Farbinformation ist ja nachträglich draufgeklatscht worden. Also schwarz-weiß Fernsehen war, glaube ich, weltweit ziemlich einheitlich. Und nur die Farbinformation ist dann das, was PAL und NTSC und die ganzen unterschiedlichen Systeme wesentlichen differenziert. Das heißt, wenn man schwarz-weiß einmal implementiert, dann kann man weltweit empfangen, aber für Farbe ist es dann eben ein bisschen schwieriger. Und da war halt derjenige, der das geschrieben hatte, der hat gesagt, oh ja, es geht, schön, ich mach jetzt was anderes. Also wer die Farbe noch dazu implementieren möchte, der kann das tun.
Es gibt auf jeden Fall noch Hacker-Bedarf.
Ja, natürlich. So, das sind so Dinge. Dann natürlich die ganzen klassischen Amateurfunk-Geschichten. Also man kann damit wunderbar sämtliche Amateurfunk-Frequenzen empfangen, auch Amateurfunk-Fernsehen, solche Dinge. Packet Radio, ja, da weiß ich jetzt nicht, wie weit da die Software gedient ist, aber ist natürlich auch eine klasse Anwendung.
Und man kann sich auch einen schönen Medienscanner damit bauen. Also ich meine, Radioempfang hat man ja nun schon ein paar Mal. Das ist damit wirklich überhaupt gar kein Problem. Eigentlich müsste man sich doch damit relativ leicht einen Computer bauen, der irgendwie alle Radiosendungen gleichzeitig empfängt, oder? Ist das auch noch schon zu viel Arbeit für das System?
Ich denke, das ist relativ realistisch, dass man das macht. Weil die FM-Radio, erstens mal ist es ein Band von nur 88 bis 120 MHz. Das geht locker. Und zweitens sind die einzelnen Kanäle extrem schmalbandig. Also im Vergleich zu den digitalen Verfahren und so. Also das sollte gehen eigentlich. Ähnlich kann man das natürlich auch, aber das wäre ja höchst illegal.
Auch wenn das über Kabel kommt?
Auch wenn es über Kabel kommt, ja. Also wir sprechen ja von analog noch nach wie vor. Was natürlich höchst illegal wäre, was man sicherlich auch sehr leicht implementieren könnte, ist sämtliche BOSS-Kanäle. Also BOSS-Funk ist ja diese Behörden- und Sicherheits-Dingstag-Funk-Kanäle gleichzeitig zu digitalisieren weg. Ich glaube, es sind 200 Kanäle mit jeweils 7 Kilohertz oder irgendwas.
Auch analog alles?
Analog alles, ja.
Ach du meinst jetzt, wo die Polizei funkt?
Ja, BOSS-Funk wird hauptsächlich, also Polizei ist ja eine Anwendung, aber auch Feuerwehr, Datumskräfte, sonstige Sachen. Und das ist glaube ich ziemlich das einzige, was man in Deutschland absolut nicht hören darf.
Also das darf man nicht machen? Haben wir da eigentlich auch gar nichts drüber geredet?
Nein, nein, man kann ja darüber reden, dass theoretisch solche Dinge machbar sind mit der Hardware und dass es sicherlich in anderen Ländern auch Jurisdiktionen gibt.
Aber es ist ja verboten und ich weiß ja nicht, wie das in unserer Szene was verboten ist. Das kommt auch gar nicht erst auf den Tisch.
Richtig.
Du kriegst noch mal so diese Idee mit dem Medienscanner, weil man könnte ja im Prinzip relativ einfach einen Computer aufsetzen, der einfach alle Radiosendungen hört sozusagen oder die ganze Zeit aufzeichnet, streamt, was auch immer. Das wäre ja auch wieder illegal. Nicht für den privaten Gebrauch.
In deiner Wohnung darfst du streamen, ja.
Na ja, ich könnte mir das ja dann sozusagen auch mobil irgendwie bereitstellen. Das heißt, egal wo ich gerade bin, könnte ich dann eben mit meinem, was auch immer, könnte ja ein Telefoninterface dafür machen und könnte einfach auf einen beliebigen Sender dann reingehen. Na gut, da könnte ich dann in dem Moment den auch auswählen, aber wissen schon. Für den Freundeskreis.
Ja, und ansonsten, ich meine, es gibt natürlich unendlich viele Einsatzgebiete, wo man auch, was man mit dem Gerät und mit der Software noch machen kann, aber da muss man halt sehr viel Software noch schreiben. Also, man soll nicht sich der Illusion hingeben, dass weil man jetzt ein Stück Hardware hat, mit dem man alles empfangen kann, man plötzlich in der Lage ist, alles zu empfangen. Man muss immer noch Entwicklungsaufwand für die einzelnen Empfänger betreiben, dass es jetzt eben Software-Entwicklung ist und nicht mehr Hardware-Entwicklung. Da muss man ein bisschen die Illusionen auch nehmen, den Leuten.
Wie ist denn das mit Senden? Kann man denn damit auch senden?
Ja, das ist in der Tat richtig. Sowohl das USRP 1 als auch die neue 2er-Variante haben Sende- und Empfangsseite. Bei den Frontends gibt es Frontends, die sogenannte Transceiver-Frontends sind, die also Sende- und Empfangsseite machen in einem Band. Und es gibt da reine Receiver-Frontends. Von dem DBS-LX, von dem wir gesprochen haben im GSM-Beispiel, ist das jetzt ein reines Empfangs-Frontend. Es gibt aber auch ein Transceiver-Frontend für 900 MHz und ein anderes für 1800, 1900 MHz. Das heißt, man bräuchte mindestens zwei davon.
Kosten die auch nur so 70 Dollar, oder ist das dann wieder teurer?
Nee, die sind dann eher so 250, 270 oder so, hab ich im Kopf. Also Sendetechnik ist halt immer gleich eine Ecke teurer als Empfangstechnik. Da ist noch auch keine Sende-Endstufe dahinter. Also die senden mittig, glaube ich, maximal 200 MW oder so, was aber auch schon einiges ist.
Und so einen Sender für den UKW-Bereich, wenn man jetzt so seinen eigenen UKW-Funk aufmachen möchte, was natürlich auch verboten ist?
Na, das ist jetzt nicht mehr verboten im Übrigen. Es gibt ja jetzt diese neuen, weiß nicht, ob du es schon gesehen hast, für MP3-Player, die steckst du einfach rein.
Ach so, also für den lokalen Bereich, in deiner Wohnung. Genau, in deiner Wohnung.
Ich denke, die Sendeleistung, also was direkt aus dem USRP oder aus den Frontlands rauskommt, ist auch nicht höher oder nur geringfügiger, ist auf jeden Fall auch in dem Bereich. Das heißt also, das kann man damit auch tun natürlich.
Das heißt, damit könnte man sich sozusagen so einen universellen Hausfunk, was man dann mit einem normalen ÖL-UKW-Radius aufstellen und was die dann so senden, das definiert man dann sozusagen mit seinem PC.
Das kann man damit tun, aber das kann man eben auch sehr viel billiger haben, indem man so ein 9-Euro-Gerät in die Soundkarte hineinsteckt. Das ist ja ein Hardware.
Das ist ja unsportlich.
Ja genau, das ist unsportlich. Das ist ja beschissen. Dafür würde ich es mir jetzt nicht zulegen, aber das ist durchaus im Rahmen des Möglichen.
RDS senden, überall Autoradios aufstellen.
Vielleicht kann man da Autoradios exploiten, wer weiß. Mit irgendwelchen Buffer-Overflows im RDS hat auch noch keiner ausprobiert. Oder auch TMC senden, das ist natürlich noch viel spannender. Hier ist Stau, fahrt alle nicht in meine Straße.
Ja richtig, TMC, das ist ja auch so eine digitale Beimengung. Wie funktioniert das genau so? Ist das so wie RDS?
Ja, ich glaube es ist ein 38 Kilohertz-Träger, der damit so reinkommt in das Ding.
Aber das ist ja so das, wovon sich so die Navigationsgeräte so ernähren. So kleine Tomtoms, die lutschen ja da auch irgendwie ihre Information bei raus.
Genau, aber gut, wenn du jetzt sozusagen großflächig die diversen Tomtoms irgendwo beeinflussen möchtest.
Wenn ich in so einer Hauptverkehrsstraße wohne und dann irgendwie so TMC aus dem Fenster rausspucke.
Könnte sein, dass man da damit interessante Dinge mit anstellen könnte. Aber das ist dann natürlich wahrscheinlich auch nicht mehr erlaubt.
Nein, das ist bestimmt nicht erlaubt, aber das wollen wir uns auch gar nicht ausmalen. Aber so ist das ja nun mal mit der Sicherheit. Solche Systeme werden designt und man bedenkt halt gar nicht erst, was irgendwelche freidrehenden Zwölfjährigen, die gerade so auf der Bildungstour sind, alles so für Kollateralschäden anstellen können, nur weil man beim Design ein bisschen geschummelt hat.
Ja, ein Punkt, den natürlich auch bei dem GSM Projekt, wo du anfangs ja schon sagtest, senden will man auch irgendwann mal. Also man möchte eigentlich schon GSM auch reden, nicht nur hören. Und dazu ist noch unendlich viel größerer Aufwand notwendig. Weniger jetzt wegen der Funksende-Seite. Also GSM senden ist eigentlich, oder überhaupt bei diesen digitalen Modulationsverfahren, ist senden in der Regel einfacher und weniger komplexer als empfangen. Das ist also nicht das Problem, sondern das Problem sind halt diese ganzen Protokolle. Es sind viele Schichten, diese ganze Multiplex-Geschichten, unglaublich viele Timer und State-Maschinen usw. usw. Also da muss einiges an Entwicklungsarbeit auf viel höheren Schichten erst mal implementiert sein. Das dann letztlich noch mit dem GNU Radio zu senden, ist ein geringeres Problem. Da ist der Teufel da noch ein bisschen im Detail, was Timing betrifft und solche Dinge. Also gerade Timing zwischen Sende- und Empfangsseite, weil wenn ich empfange und das dann in den Software erst alles rechnen muss, dann muss ich halt relativ schnell auch wieder was zurück senden können. Also die Frage ist die Roundtrip-Ratency, ob die irgendwie ausreicht und so. Aber das, glaube ich, ist alles machbar. Nicht desto trotz, bis die höheren Schichten, bis da mal irgendwie was da ist. Ich denke, das wird noch eine ganze Zeit dauern.
Also die Vision ist schon so, dass man mit so einem Laptop um den Hals durch die Gegend läuft, das USRP-3 in der Hand haltend. Kann man dann sozusagen mit seinem Laptop auch telefonieren. Nicht, dass man es auch mit so einem billigen Handy machen könnte, aber das ist ja auch wieder unsportlich eigentlich.
Ja, also ich denke, das ist ja auch sehr realistisch.
Ja, und öffnet dann aber auch wirklich das Türchen zu wahrer Verschlüsselung dann auch. Oder? So für Telefongespräche?
Nein, leider nein. Das GSM ist halt so unglaublich asymmetrisch oder wie soll ich sagen, also es ist ein Netz, wo es unglaublich viele sehr funktionsspezifische Komponenten gibt. Es ist nicht so Peer-to-Peer-mäßig, wie wir das im Netz kennen, also im Internet, mit End-to-End und irgendwie die Intelligenz ist auf den Endsechnern und das Netz leitet nur weiter dazwischen, sondern es ist umgekehrt. Es ist unglaublich viel Intelligenz im Netz. Dazu gehört auch, dass das Netz zum Beispiel nach gut dünkem Die-Voice-Daten transcodeet.
Ah, verstehe. Das heißt also, ja, nur …Man kann nicht einfach mal das so nehmen und scrambleen, sondern das geht dann gleich schief.
Richtig, weil das kein transparenter Datenkanal ist, sondern das sind halt Voice-Daten. Und schon allein auf der Luftschnittstelle zwischen Telefon- und Basisstation, glaube ich, gibt es mindestens drei verschiedene Codecs, die verwendet werden. Also Full-Rate und Half-Rate-Codecs. Und dann kann das Netz eben intern beliebig sonst irgendwas umcodieren und halt wieder zurückcodieren oder was auch immer tun. Also sobald du eben das öffentliche Netz verwendest, ich sage jetzt öffentlich, aber halt einen Netzbetreiber verwendest, den du nicht kontrollierst, dann hast du da keine Chance. Ich sehe zumindest keine.
Gut, ich denke, wir müssen langsam mal zum Ende kommen. Ich würde ganz gerne noch mal zum Schluss kurz fragen, wenn man jetzt kein USRP hat, sich aber nur das GNU Radio als solches installiert, was kann man damit Nützliches und Spannendes schon machen, was jetzt vielleicht für den interessierten Hörer interessant sein mag?
Und das dann einfach irgendwo auf ihren Webserver legen. Das gleiche auch für DECT. Für DECT nicht öffentlich, also diese Gruppe, in der ich auch involviert bin, die sich mit DECT beschäftigt, wir haben dann nur intern die Daten bisher, das ist nicht öffentlich. Aber eben sobald man zusammen mit anderen Leuten arbeitet, wo irgendjemand so ein Gerät hat, dann kann der ja die Rohdaten erstmal liefern. Bis man dann bei diesem Dump alles dekodiert hat und die Software soweit hat, dass das jedes letzte Bit in diesem Dump versteht, dann macht halt irgendjemand anders mal wieder einen anderen Dump. Vielleicht aus einem anderen Land, mit einem anderen Operator jetzt bei GSM. Und dann kann man wieder die Software drauf laufen lassen und kann die Software soweit bringen, dass sie alles da drin versteht.
Auch so für andere Sachen wie RFID zum Beispiel, man mag es vielleicht auch Dumpklägen geben.
Richtig, richtig. Also überhaupt ist es ein sehr übliches, wenn man sich diese GNU Radio Mailing-Liste oder auch die von GSM Projekt anschaut, dann ist es sehr üblich, dass die Leute einfach, auch auf dem lokalen Rechner macht man das selten live, sondern man schneidet erst mal mit, weil dann hat man es reproduzierbar. Man möchte ja seine Software verbessern, iterativ üblicherweise. Dann hat man eben eine Datenbasis und mit der arbeitet man. Wenn man irgendein Problem hat, dann kann man auch anderen Leuten sagen, hier schaut mal dieser Dampf, da ist dies oder jenes komisch, kann mir das jemand erklären und so. Es wird sehr viel mit diesen Mitschnitten gearbeitet und dadurch ist es auch leicht für Leute, die jetzt keine Hardware haben, dort mit einzusteigen.
Und ich könnte mir vorstellen, GNU Radio ist auch ein schönes Spielzeug für Leute, die sich im Studium befinden, von den diversesten Disziplinen.
Das ist richtig, es werden auch tatsächlich...
Musiker, Elektrotechniker.
Ja, ja. Also am meisten natürlich schon von Elektrotechnikern mit Schwerpunkt Kommunikationstechnologie. Und es ist so, dass auch dort, dass ein größerer Kunde oder eine größere Abnahme, also Universitäten kaufen gerne diese USRPs. In den USA gibt es da einige, die da zusammenarbeiten mit den USRP-Leuten. Und die kaufen halt gleich mal so einen Klassensatz irgendwie von den Geräten.
Weil es ja auch einfach ein gutes System ist, um überhaupt erst mal neue Protokolle auch zu erfinden. Ich meine, wenn man jetzt darüber nachdenkt, wie man so Next-Generation-Digital-Kommunikation von was weiß ich macht, bevor man jetzt anfängt, große Masken aufzustellen, muss man das Ganze auch erst mal simulieren. Was könnte man Besseres tun, als es in Software zu simulieren, sozusagen Dumps zu erzeugen? Das heißt, der eine macht die Sendeseite in Software, der andere macht die Empfangsseite in Software. Dann hat man sozusagen schon mal alles, da ist noch nicht eine Welle durch die Luft gegangen. Dann kann man das dann mit viel Testen nochmal ausprobieren.
Richtig. Man kann also tatsächlich auch solche Dinge, das ist auch ein Anwendungsfall von GNU Radio, so Dinge zu simulieren. Weil ja die Sendeseite unterstützt wird, hat man ja auch Building Blocks für so was wie einen Oszillator und einen Modulator und die ganze Sendeseite. Ich habe zum Beispiel auch, als wir RFID-Hardware entwickelt haben, die gar nichts mit Software-Defined Radio und GNU Radio zu tun hatte, habe ich einfach mit GNU Radio Simulationen gemacht. Da habe ich gesagt, na ja, jetzt nehme ich hier mal einen Träger mit 13,56 MHz und packe da mal ein virtuelles Datensignal, also etwas drauf, moduliere das mal und dann füge ich ein bisschen Rauschen hinzu. Ich habe ja auch einen Rauschgenerator und kann das hinzufügen und schaue mal, wie das signalen, dann schicke ich das durch einen Filter und was kommt hinterher eigentlich noch raus? Kann ich noch irgendwie was sehen?
Auch eine Störung zu simulieren.
Genau, richtig. Solche Dinge rein, nur die Simulation ist genauso möglich, also überhaupt gar kein Thema. Und gerade auch zur Visualisierung sind eben Module, das hatte ich noch gar nicht erwähnt, dabei für Frequenz-Spektrum, Oszillograf und derartige Dinge. Ich glaube inzwischen auch für so Wasserfall-Diagramme. Also gerade ich denke in Forschung und Lehre sicherlich sehr interessant. Und auch interessant unter dem Aspekt, dass es eben freie Software ist. Auch die Hardware des USRP ist völlig offen. Jeder könnte das nachbauen, wenn er wollte, ohne irgendwelche Lizenzgebühren zu zahlen oder ähnliches. Die Platinen-Files sind offen. Also wenn jemand sich das selber löten möchte, kann er das tun.
Oder falls halt jemand für irgendein Projekt eine spezielle Adaption davon braucht. Gilt das eigentlich auch für alle Frontends?
Das gilt auch für alle Frontends, die offiziell von den GNU Radio und USRP-Machern gemacht wird. Also da gibt es den Matt Atos, der die Hardware macht. Und alles, was der macht, ist offen. Also bis hin zum Bestückungsplan und Bill of Materials und alles.
Aber es gibt da nicht so eine GPL-artige Hardware-Lizenz, die vorschreibt, dass alles, was man da reinsteckt, auch derselben Lizenz gemacht wird?
Kann ich dir jetzt gar nichts sagen. Das könnte durchaus sein. Ich weiß nicht, wie es mit der Hardware-Seite ist, aber GNU Radio ist ja, wie der Name impliziert, ein offizielles GNU-Projekt und verwendet damit natürlich auch FSF-Lizenzen, allen voran RGPL, wie es jetzt mit den Hardwaren ist, das kann ich jetzt nicht auswendig sagen, was da Sache ist. Aber es ist trotzdem jedenfalls, gerade auch für Unis oder für wen auch immer, der sich damit beschäftigen will, man ist halt nicht an einen Hersteller gebunden. Wenn man jetzt erst mal in das System investiert und Leute damit arbeiten lässt, dann ist man nicht davon abhängig, dass der Hersteller sagt, ach nee, das bauen wir jetzt nicht mehr, sondern es gibt jetzt nur den Nachfolger und ihr müsst lauter neue Geräte kaufen oder solche Dinge. Oder, oh, das wird nicht mehr supportet und diese ganzen Dinge, die sind halt irgendwie dann Vergangenheit.
Gut, ich denke, jetzt haben wir es. Wir sind schon auch über zwei Stunden am Plappern hier, meine Herren. Aber da war jetzt auch eine Menge drin. Das war eine dichte Sendung, da habe ich eine Weile brauchen, bis ich da die ganzen Links so rausgeprokelt habe. Aber es gibt sie wie immer auf der Webseite Chaosradio ccc.de zu dieser Sendung, Chaosradio Express 87. Und finden sich natürlich dann auch in dieser mp3-Datei, die ich publizieren werde, wieder in den Lyrics, wie gehabt. Es gibt sonst noch wertvolle Hinweise, die wir noch unbedingt erwähnen sollten. Mir fällt auch ein, dass wir irgendwann auch noch mal hier über unser Sputnik-Projekt vielleicht sprechen. So, darauf soll hier auf jeden Fall demnächst auch noch mal ein Thema sein, weil Chaosradio Express sich ja auch im Security-Bereich einiges getan hat. Ja, dann bleibt uns eigentlich nur noch das Armen. Mahlzeit. Mahlzeit, genau, unter dieser Sendung zu setzen. Vielen Dank, Harald, für die ausführlichen Informationen und vielen Dank an die Hörer beim Wiederholen und Zuhören dieser Sendung, wie ich schon im Blog berichtet habe. Chaosradio Express hat mit der ersten Sendung auch schon die 10.000-Hörer-Grenze durchschritten. So soll es weitergehen. Ich bette ja immer um Feedback. Das werde ich jetzt auch diesmal noch mal tun in unserem Blog und so. Was ich nicht gesagt habe, was ich aber jetzt mal tue, ist, wenn ihr Chaosradio hört und wenn ihr das interessant findet, dann erzählt es weiter. Empfiehlt uns weiter. Bloggt darüber, wenn ihr einen Blog habt oder nutzt andere Kommunikationskanäle. Ich freue mich immer am meisten, wenn du über die Sendung nimmst. Das war's. Bis bald bei Chaosradio Express.